all right welcome everybody it is
another day and another emergency that
is growing and growing and we will have
a press conference from Donald Trump
momentarily scheduled for the top of the
hour and these have often started very
late it's never really clear why they
start late at one point the idea was
maybe it's timed to try to impact the
market in one way or another but it's
Saturday so that's certainly not the
case today they're just late and there
we've been covering these all week and I
appreciate everybody who's who's joining
me for them and of course you know
welcome like and subscribe and get
memberships and send Super chats and all
of that stuff but putting all of those
issues of paramount importance aside
these press conferences are completely
delusional and with the exception of
about maybe there was like a three and a
half minute period during the Wednesday
press conference during Donald Trump
during which Donald Trump sort of
behaved like a normal person
these are completely delusional lie
riddled press conferences where
journalists are attacked for asking very
basic questions Donald Trump promotes
you know medications and treatments that
while they may they have some promise
and I've been covering them it promotes
them as if we've got a treatment now and
everything's great despite the fact that
he has no medical knowledge whatsoever
disagrees with what the actual medical
experts on the stage are saying and it
these are just you know what I would
like to see and I have a few notes of
things I want to talk about I would like
to have the so I think the press corps
other than the crazy people like Sean
Spicer and Oh a n are in the press corps
it's crazy they were in the room
yesterday aside from that Donald Trump's
belligerence and attacks on the press
corps and I'll show you an example in a
second I think that it's starting to
unify the press corps where they say we
can't be treated like this we're here at
risk to our health in order to report on
what's going on I would like to see
every time Trump doesn't answer a
question when it's asked the next
reporter should ask the exact same
question and say I'm gonna ask this
again because you didn't answer the last
question and then
doesn't answer the third person should
say the same thing forced Trump either
to attack all of them and walk off the
stage without answering a single
question which is essentially what's
happening just in a more propagandized
way or maybe he will concede that he's
he what he's saying is not true I doubt
he would I think he would simply go
through everybody and then walk off the
stage and end it early and then maybe
from then on we would just hear from the
medical experts I don't even think we
need to hear from Trump but during these
press briefings to be perfectly frank I
would be fine hearing from dr. Burks and
dr. fowey and I mean they're the two who
have been least propagandized that
that's what I would like to see I don't
think it's going to happen
let's go momentarily I want to go in a
second to the Peter Alexander attack
from yesterday before we do that Chris
says does David own a bidet I do not
Jimmy big nut says hi DP I'm a big fan
of Debussy do you like Debussy I do I do
the like Debussy very much and Sam Kim
Ian Kenyon has grabbed a soy boil ever
level membership on on YouTube I
appreciate that
we do have a 25 member goal we do have
the discount I won't spend too much time
on that just make sure as you're coming
in on Twitch make sure you follow our
channel as you're entering on Facebook
make sure you have liked our page and as
you're arriving on YouTube make sure to
both like and subscribe like and
subscribe so this was yesterday let's
take a look at what happened yesterday
this was a pretty basic question you
know to call it bait it's not bait it's
millions of people think Trump is
incompetent and we want to hear from
what he has to say and Trump just going
off on Peter Alexander 14,000 Dorset
Millions
as you witness who are scared right now
wait Americans we're watching you right
now you're scared I say that you're a
terrible reporter that's what I say it's
a very nasty question and I think it's a
very bad signal that you're putting out
to the American people American people
and again remember the trumps acting
like no one would be scared unless Peter
Alexander said people are scared no
people
scared half the country seems not to be
I'll have some news about that people go
into the beaches I had friends texting
me saying hey are you traveling to
Europe in a couple weeks like no I'm not
leaving my house guys but the the
question is a completely fair one and
Trump could have you know people are
this is only a bait question if you
consider Trump to be completely
incapable of showing any empathy
whatsoever which he is right but Trump
could say I understand people are scared
these are unprecedented times but what I
can tell you and what I know is that we
have a resiliency and determination to
say little right let mean like sound
like Obama basically is what I'm saying
Trump can't do it so this is what he
does looking for answers and they're
looking for hope and you're doing
sensationalism and the same with NBC and
Cohn cast something that's really bad
reporting and you want to get back to
reporting instead of sensationalism
let's see if it works it might and it
might not I happen to feel good about it
but who knows I've been right a lot
let's see what happened so that that is
that is someone who is increasingly
completely out of control right I mean
he has no idea and I did want to see if
the White House is gonna have a stream
as well they don't seem to yet so we're
waiting we're waiting for the Trump
press conference at the top of the hour
that's how you answer if you don't know
what's going on and you don't know what
to do the question was perfectly fine
and reasonable it was it took be perfect
guys it was a freaking softball question
any other president would be able to
take that and turn it into a 30-second
inspirational soundbite Trump has to
attack the messenger on it and and it is
not it is not looking good whatsoever
okay number two there's been a lot of
promise I have a list I make a list for
all of these streams where I have things
I want to mention to you guys there have
been things promised over the last eight
days that just aren't happening so last
Friday Donald Trump promised this
website where you would be able to type
in your symptoms it would give you
information
it would assess whether you should get a
test and tell you where the closest
place is to get a test what happened
nobody's even talking about that anymore
that promise was made eight days ago we
don't have it number two checks check
supposedly are coming to people every
single day since last week we've been
hearing about the checks are going we're
gonna send money is it going to be a
thousand or twelve hundred two thousand
and one installment in two installments
what are we going to do for small
businesses we need something for small
businesses we got nothing okay
and every day we hear a new proposal and
this is why when in the super chat
people say David can you comment on X or
Y proposal until something becomes a
reality I don't think it's worth wasting
your time commenting on hypothetical
proposals we need to get money to people
yesterday I was at I did some shopping
at Trader Joe's in Brookline as I
mentioned and I went over to Michael's
deli great deli in Brookline picked up
some pastrami some knishes just the
staples you know and I was talking with
Steve who owns it about how at some
point you know mortgages there's gonna
need to be some kind of postponing rent
for businesses if you even want
businesses to stay open on a takeout
only basis or whatever to feed people
the landlord still want the rent from
the business so you're gonna have to do
something about that because otherwise
you're gonna have businesses saying I'm
just walking away I'll just shut that
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna work to lose
money because of the rent that I can't
make I'll just walk away from the
business and then it's gonna be
compounding economic disaster so in any
case we haven't seen any of that stuff
whatsoever okay for people wondering
what's going on you haven't missed
anything we're seven minutes from the
scheduled start of the of today's press
conference they've tended to start late
and we are live on Facebook twitch and
YouTube if you have any questions
comments anything if you're watching on
YouTube send it by super chat and it'll
pop up in that gray box which is sadly
empty right now in the lower left of the
screen if you're watching on Twitch you
can include a message with your twitch
subscription Prime or otherwise and
it'll show up in that vertical blue rect
at the top and then if you really want
to support the work that we are doing
we've been covering these streams every
day with your commentary remember to
grab a membership at join pakman.com we
youtube you YouTube what are called
YouTube CPMs are down about 20 30 40
percent and it's getting pretty ugly out
there now I'm hearing from people that
this has been rescheduled let me see
president Trump schedule today I don't
believe it has but let's just take a
look at it
according to Trump's schedule today it's
it's interesting it's on Trump's
schedule at both 12:00 and 12:30 either
way will will be here until it starts
let me show you there's a I always check
out Trump's schedule for the day you'll
notice it's often very very light often
very little on the schedule today we
have a 12:00 briefing and now it also
says 12:30 briefing so it's conceivably
possible that it did get rescheduled for
12:30 and then Trump has a 2:00 p.m.
phone call and that's it guys otherwise
it's just tweeting and you know Fox News
and you know golf simulator at the White
House and stuff like that but this is
the this is Trump's full schedule today
in the midst of in the in the midst of a
growing major major crisis FRA salt says
via super chat fifty-five percent of
America approves of Trump's response
that's insane I saw that Jay Harper says
guys like the video yes remember if you
are watching on YouTube hit like for
this stream and make sure to hit
subscribe we've got three thousand
people watching and only three hundred
likes that's sad
that's it depresses me when I see that I
guess people are maybe furious with me
for some reason that I can't discern
over on Twitch let me say thanks to 503
Phoenix for subscribing with twitch
prime okay so we did the Peter Alexander
clip we talked about what's where's all
that promised stuff I talked about I
want reporters just repeating the same
question and and essentially forcing
Trump to either answer it or walk
offstage okay one of the lies that we
keep
hearing everyday is anybody who wants a
test can get one value right so and
that's not true now I spoke to a friend
yesterday this friend is experiencing
symptoms and works somewhere where there
is now there was a known coronavirus
case at this person's job so symptoms
within five days of someone with corona
virus having been there this person
needs to be tested this person also has
kids and this person asked their doctor
so what do I do
the doctor said listen don't come in
we're really busy just call if your
symptoms get worse okay well what about
isolating from my kids well listen you
you haven't tested positive at this
point so don't worry too much about that
I haven't tested positive because I
haven't been tested this is like saying
I have great news
you've not failed the math test well the
math test is tomorrow what can we really
glean anything from the fact that I've
not failed the test I haven't taken this
is happening everywhere and and every
single day Donald Trump continues to
insist we've got more than enough tests
for 14 days now they've been saying
every day we are adding tens of
thousands of tests per day in capacity
so understand what that means right 14
days ago they if their capacity was
5,000 they say we're adding 20,000 so
you should be able to do twenty five
thousand a day day two you should be
able to do forty five thousand a day day
three you should be able to do sixty
five thousand a day look at the numbers
of tests done it's not happening it's
it's just flat-out not happening and
it's it's quite frankly stunning that
this is these talking points are even
allowed by the press corps at this point
in time um Walker Anderson says her
Bernie supporters refusing to vote Biden
in the general effectively admitting
Trump isn't that bad Trump gets an
unfair shake he has pros and cons
hurricane Brenda says where is Joe Biden
he's missing till Monday Monday he's
going to reappear Nancy Barnard says
I've been a member since 2013 thank you
for your great work David I'm an
essential retail worker in San Francisco
tell people to stay home while on
shelter in yeah a friend of mine sent me
a message today this is let me pull it
up and said hey I'm starting to think my
trip to Europe in three weeks might not
happen but maybe a slim chance I could
are you making other travel plans are
you traveling in the US and I said no
I'm not even leaving my house other than
to get groceries and walk around you
know in the outdoors exposed and not
exposed that you know far from people
everything's canceled why are you even
leaving your house unless necessary we
may have a shelter in place soon like
these are these are friends of mine that
I consider to be quite competent quite
frankly and so this is why you know then
you hear Republican congressman are
having group lunches at restaurants that
they're thrilled or empty and now they
can get a nice table at because
everybody's supposed to be staying home
I mean we're screwed we're screwed
yesterday I cancelled three flights it
was two with American and one with Delta
and you don't even have to call there
you can cancel I immediately got a full
credit even though they were
non-refundable flights no change fee I
called the hotel in Miami where I was
scheduled to stay in a few days and said
I'm canceling they said can you tell us
the reason why I said yeah coronavirus
is the reason why so yeah listen by the
way people who are talking up suggests
oh I have to talk about something else I
need to ban excuse me while I absolutely
unleash a brutal banhammer on people
both on super on YouTube and on twitch
just give me a second here I'm banning
people by the dozens because we have
stuff going on listen I know but some
people might think it's funny to start
saying take ibuprofen if you think you
have coronavirus you guys have to cut
the [ __ ] okay
and for people who don't know there are
there's a question now as to whether
ibuprofen actually worsens symptoms and
I there's an article from yesterday that
teenagers are finding it funny to go to
grocery stores and COFF on produce on
fruits and vegetables we're just not
going to do it okay so people might
moderators please if you see people
doing this stuff you got to just we're
dropping the banhammer right away okay
we're not we're not gonna play around
with that
and obviously with the anti-semitism as
well though there's been a little bit a
little bit less of the anti-semitism as
this has been going on but we're not
we're not doing any of that stuff it's
it's pernt these are perma bans all
right thank you okay
Chris says where is Biden the Dems
should be having him all over the place
to make him look like he's taking
leadership on this even social media
speeches yeah
Joe Biden has been Joe hidin lately but
I've read that starting Monday he's
going to be doing shadow press
conferences basically just um parallel
press conferences coronavirus briefings
to Donald Trump so we will see oh people
are asking about free stuff from the
David Pakman show store with memberships
yes so what we did yesterday and this
actually worked really well what I used
to do was I would say right now we're at
0 new members by the way which is
depressing it's horrible horrible
horrible but eventually I think someone
will sign up of up until yesterday what
I was doing was I would say new member
number 5 or 10 or whatever will get a
free item from my store like the
infamous data mail t-shirt and people
said David that's not a good idea
because everybody will wait until you
get to 4:00 to try to be number five so
what we did yesterday was I will just
give out a free item for every five
memberships will contact people one out
of every five so like yesterday during
the stream we had thirteen people sign
up so we did two free items we contacted
them everybody wants the data mail
t-shirt it's hilarious we've shipped
these already to seven countries and and
and more coming in the most popular
color is heather gray I ordered one in
white and I'm waiting on it right now
but so ever for every five subscribe
you
sorry about that guys I hit the wrong
button there I appear I apologize for
that I apologize I think I might have I
don't think you were able to hear me
when I said Bernie cone Murray has
gifted for subscriptions which I love
Andrew Akkad has also everything falling
off the walls here rue Akkad also
subscribing on on Twitch very much
appreciated ok one other thing that I
want to talk about let's see if we can
do a little data and math I'll just turn
the volume up here so we won't miss that
so one of the I think it's really
important that we don't minimize or go
crazy over what's going on but everybody
just needs to be staying the hell in
their house period and that's it ok but
I do want to talk about one piece of
math which is the growth factor okay so
the growth factor is the rate at which
cases are growing over the previous days
cases okay so when you look at total
cases daily new cases obviously this
doesn't look good but something when
we're talking about viral spread there's
a question of is the rate of growth
increasing okay this is sort of like the
it's it's a calculus sort of thing so
it's a really important thing to
understand let me see if I can pull up
maybe calculator is is useful for this
let's see if we can do this so lately as
you can see the growth pack factor has
been right around call it 1.2 if the
growth factor itself continues to
increase that's much worse than a steady
growth factor which still leads to more
cases so imagine that one day you have a
thousand new cases and then the next day
you have eleven hundred new cases okay
that is a growth factor of what we would
call one point one now the thing about
that is then if from one day to the next
you add another ten percent you now have
but you you would then get to twelve
hundred and ten new cases and then you
would get to what would that be to ten
thirteen hundred and forty whatever
the number of new cases can continue to
increase every single day without an
increase in the growth factor and
obviously unless and until you get the
growth factor under 1 the problem will
keep getting worse but imagine how much
worse it would be if the growth factor
was going from one point two to one
point three to one point four to one
point five before you know it it's
you're really far from getting it to one
what is the only piece of slightly okay
information that I have for you today
is that the growth factor as we have so
many new cases and community spread is
sticking between 1.15 and 1.3 this means
hopefully that within a few more days we
will start to see the effect because
remember when we learn about a new case
that's usually a case from 7 to 10 days
prior if you have your first symptom on
day 1 and you go to the hospital on day
5 and you get a test on day 6 and you
get results on day 8 on day 8 we see a
case that is actually eight days old
that's why these measures take a while
to see what we will hopefully see is
that the growth factor will will start
to decline or at least not increase and
that is often how these things spread
and the numbers that we see I'm finding
something right and then of course
there's this issue of if we aren't
testing then the growth factor will be
will be artificially low and on that
note in fact let's go to the official
numbers the official numbers are now
almost 300,000 with 12,000 deaths this
number has got to be Millions guys I
mean it's like there's places in Africa
where we think there are no cases
they're just not testing there are cases
you know the United States if you look
at the numbers in the United States
22,000 we obviously have way way way
more than that and one thing that is
also very concerning is it takes a very
long time to recover the u.s. now has
22,000 official cases and we know of a
hundred and forty-seven recoveries there
have been more deaths than recoveries
the recovery is often taking longer than
the death I believe that it's something
like on average seven
18 days for cases that end in death it
takes 17 days on average to get their
recoveries are often taking longer
longer than that so it's I'm not gonna
downplay that it's a [ __ ] show if we can
keep that growth factor relatively low
as they and Oh fair point there may be
some not good reporting of recoveries
that that's fair
or it may be delayed but it's it's
getting very very ugly guys it's getting
very ugly everybody's got to stay the
hell home that's what I doing I'm doing
and I'm going stir-crazy okay let's let
me thank a few people who have grabbed
memberships Vasia the hair ma jeez I'm
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly is
new member number one today I appreciate
that thank you for signing up Jonathan
salmon tennis is new member number two
at join pakman.com and Blake strode
Blake strode is new member number three
I also want to thank Ben Taylor Ben
Taylor has just ordered oh it's not a
beta male t-shirt oh no it's a David
Pakman show t-shirt okay very very good
but uh the beta male t-shirts are widely
available and they are flying out
they're flying out not from here we
don't have any here but from the from
the manufacturer okay we are standing by
for the start of Donald Trump's
emergency press conference and by
emergency I mean he can't stop lying and
that's the emergency that's what's an
emergency about it if you're just
joining us on YouTube please make sure
to LIKE the stream and to hit subscribe
if you are watching on twitch make sure
to follow
I want to thank Comstock rocker for
subscribing for the fifth month in a row
with twitch prime I appreciate that and
also everybody watching on Facebook I
also appreciate you guys I know it's
Facebook doesn't provide great tools for
having you send comments and whatnot
while we are live the interface is just
it's a mess but I appreciate everybody
who's been watching on Facebook as well
okay let me do a couple other super
chats which have been flying in here
[Music]
okay here we go
Constance Neal says are you satisfied
with Democrats in Congress responses
well I'm not satisfied with the fact
that we still don't have any checks or
small business support how much of it is
Democrats Republicans fall I don't know
but overall our leaders are failing us
thanks to jigged one for the twitch
Prime subscription appreciate that as
well a Kowalski from Nebraska says where
do I send your steaks we're gonna have
to email me about that we do have a p.o
box where we have someone in a hazmat
suit grab the mail for safety reasons
but I don't know if you send them with
dry ice or how it all works
haruka Gotoh says do two racists like
Trump I'm afraid to visit the USA well
listen nobody should be traveling
anywhere at this point in time Mark
Davis says hello from nowhere Kansas
home of the Spanish flu that's right the
Spanish flu widely considered to have
originated either in Kansas France or
there's one other place there's one
other place that don't remember now
which where is Jamal Swift says hi DP
Thank You Jamal Charlie says did you see
Trump's tweet about the meds yeah you
know again sometimes it's like a little
bit of information is worse than total
ignorance Donald Trump tweeted earlier
today and again I tweeted about this a
week ago right so this is not it's it's
I'll just tell you what he said
hydroxychloroquine and as if throw
Meissen taken together have a real
chance to be one of the biggest game
changers in the history of medicine
the FDA has moved mountains thank you
hopefully they will both hydrochloric
wine works better with as the throw
Meissen International Journal of
microbial agents be put in use
immediately people are dying move fast
and God bless everyone so listen I I
have been from day one if you guys have
been watching this chat my channel you
would have known a week ago about
hydroxychloroquine plus azithromycin
it's a non blinded small study from a
medical not a medical from from a doctor
a medical doctor here's what I mean a
done in France named DDA Rao
and it's enough that it means we should
be studying it okay but we don't we
don't yet know whether it's going to be
an effective treatment and one of the
important things is when the study is
not blinded to the doctor if I'm a
doctor and I have 50 patients and I know
which ones get the hydroxychloroquine
and as a throme Ison and which ones
don't
I may have an implicit bias I may give
that treatment to patients that are I
believe are more likely to do better
with it or patients that are more likely
to recover
anyway spontaneously this is why these
things have to be blinded the patients
need to not know who's getting which
treatment the doctors need to not know
who's getting which treatment because
otherwise there's experimenters bias and
all of this other stuff so it is not
enough data it is promising it is
promising but Donald Trump is tweeting
stuff like this which is irresponsible
acting like we may have a cure and then
you've got Republican Republicans
including members of Congress and just
you know dumb Republican voters who are
going around you know going to
restaurants and saying it's all
overblown and it's all a hoax and
whatever the case may be we are still
standing by for the press conference at
the top of the hour okay let me say
thanks to a few new people who have
signed up here let me see I don't want
to miss anybody I don't want to miss a
single person here John McCormack is new
member number four today thanks John
appreciate that and Philip Boyle is new
member number five every five we're
doing a free item from the store so
that's that's one free item one of the
first five you'll get an email after the
stream telling you who gets the free
item from the store moving on let me say
thanks to McHale Davis who has grabbed a
data male t-shirt from the website and
also want to say thanks to Mark Davis
whose new member number six today Bo
mongrel is new member number seven today
at join pakman.com and max I don't know
how to pronounce this is it a silent J
is it max
Thiessen who is new member number eight
today
silent jays are less common in uh in
English I must say oh and also Julie
cajolá Julie cajolá is new member number
nine also want to say thanks to Chris
Simpson who has grabbed a data male
t-shirt we'll be getting that out to
Virginia very very soon I guess this
press conference has been rescheduled
for 12:30 originally this was on Trump's
calendar at noon it's not been removed
it's just that now there's another entry
at 12:30 that it will be a Donald Trump
press briefing to catch you up on what
we've gone through so far we played the
Peter Alexander clay you know what let
me just play it one more time just
because we have time this was Trump
yesterday being asked a total softball
question and by Peter Alexander and just
lashing out and attacking the reporter
and you know this was a moment where he
could have been presidential he was not
214,000 or set millions as you witness
who are scared right now wait a single
Americans we're watching you right now
gore cetera I say that you're a terrible
reporter that's what I say I think it's
a very bad signal that you're putting
out to the American people the American
people are looking for answers and
they're looking for hope and you're
doing sensationalism and the same with
NBC and Comcast I don't work let me just
say something that's really bad
reporting and you want to get back to
reporting good what's funny is there was
no reporting he simply said a lot of
people are scared what do you say to
them people are dying that that's not
that who's questioning that it's not
reporting it's a question what happens
anyway so we watched that earlier today
I mentioned we looked at some of the
growth rate math I mentioned that a lot
of things that have been promised
including the website that will sort of
triage symptoms and direct you to a
testing center
that was promised eight days ago we
don't have it checks were promised last
week small business support was promised
last week we don't have any of it and
most importantly I pointed out these
press briefings have become completely
delusional
they are just riddled with Donald Trump
lying and lying and lying and lying I we
need to see the press corps hold him
accountable what's happening is
absolutely and completely toxic and I I
would prefer just to be hearing for
medical professionals I think the press
briefings would be far more informative
if we heard just from doctor foul Qi and
dr. Burks and in fact I would say I
would prefer to hear from them without
Trump either even on the stage I think
Trump's mere presence on the stage
impacts a little bit of what we hear
from dr. Brooks and foul Qi because
obviously what they know is true is the
opposite of what Trump says they're only
they're being careful when Trump is on
stage I think we just shouldn't even
have Trump on the stage whatsoever okay
other Super chats coming in and remember
if you're just joining us this was
rescheduled from 12:00 to 12:30 and
we're expecting to get live video from
the room pretty soon uh we're ease Griff
Tavares Griffin says I work at the
airport in Atlanta none of the employees
are being tested we had two TSA agents
infected here and they're still not
testing us yep yep that's it's just
happening Brody Andrew Mulligan says
reminder Medical Reserve Corps needs
volunteers hurricane Brenda says what
good are my taxes and small business
taxes if the government isn't going to
help them yeah Arnie Klingman has
grabbed a YouTube membership it's worth
two k9 says huge game change on virus
googled the color G plan you know what I
don't know what that is and it could be
horrible sometimes people say crazy
crazy things oh boy yeah I'm not I'm
gonna have to read more about that yeah
cuz that seems to be a neo-nazi thing so
we're not I don't know about that number
420 pencil and Laura O'Connor as well as
Travis Benji have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions truth is nuance says
political ideology is thrown at the
window in times like these Trump is a
socialist and Trudeau is a Xena phone
Xena phone that's interesting
Nik one says David is it possible Trump
downplayed kovat so long to ensure his
buddies all got out of the market before
February 24 I posted about this on your
subreddit - yeah I tweeted about this
earlier let me show you by the way
always feel free to retweet anything
that I that I put out there let's see
where did where was it I said now that
we learned about the Republican stock
dumps is it possible Trump downplayed
coronavirus for weeks specifically to
allow his friends time oh I put you dump
to dump stock before the crash I just
realized a thousand likes on that tweet
that's not bad I didn't even notice that
now by the way a lot of people are
saying didn't Dianne Feinstein dump - or
are we calling her no guys
Dianne Feinstein from what I've read was
not at the briefing in which these other
Republicans learned the apocalypse is
coming and Dianne Feinstein's trades are
bad trades Dianne Feinstein apparently
sold a health care stock before
coronavirus healthcare stocks likely to
be good investments so I don't know that
I don't know that the Dianne Feinstein
thing is is relevant to what we're
talking about let me say thank you -
let's see
lol rel toe has grabbed the twitch Prime
subscription political puppy has gifted
a subscription Kankuro has subscribed
with prime and Bernie Cohn Murray has
cheered a thousand bits thank you very
much let me say thanks to some other
folks who are signing up here okay
meek high yield Davis is new member
number 1010 means we're gonna give out a
second item from the store appreciate
that
rose-colored glasses a user named
rose-colored glasses is new member
number 11 Richard Steven is new member
number 12 thanks Richard Shilo jonna's
is new member number 13 maybe it's just
jones and michelle mayfield baski is new
member number 14 will give away another
every item at at number 15 we may be
anywhere from you know ten to forty
minutes from the start of this Donald
Trump has been remarkably consistently
starting late during these press
conferences other super chats continuing
to come in a trans droid 86 as officials
at my job determine our ability to work
by assessing whether or not we look
contagious scary thought is I work in
pediatric oncology that is horrifying
that is horrifying i I have friends who
are doctors here in the Boston area and
things are being taken pretty seriously
here but even still like I I have a
friend who just who's a doctor just got
back from Europe and they said you've
got a quarantine we're giving you a test
the day you get back and you've got a
quarantine 14 days before you can come
back to work and he said great what
about groceries and they said I don't
know just kind of do whatever you need
to do okay I mean these are tough
questions I'm not pretending that
there's easy answers to these questions
Richard merg Leah as well as Jamie Soto
and Ananda Meade a have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions Heath Evans says I'm from
Wyoming and many here think this isn't a
big deal I've seen couples and families
with multiple children walking the
stores were screwed I fear that you are
correct my friend I fear that you are
correct let's see I'm getting a
notification that the YouTube video is
maybe not happening super smooth right
now can just can people on YouTube tell
me where that whether everything's still
okay on YouTube is I got some I'm
getting a notification that the YouTube
video is maybe problematic right now
same on twitch oh there might have just
been a glitch there let me know if we've
recovered guys some skipping okay yeah
it seems like there was a little bit of
an interference in my internet tubes
it's choppy had to refresh okay
hopefully it uh let me just see here
I've got to just let me just refresh
something just to see if we can get that
back under control
I think that it's possible my internet
connection might might have glitched
just very very briefly hopefully
hopefully you go back okay we seem to be
back all right very good
okay I think I think that we're okay now
all right continuing to read super chats
let me see here we skip to the bottom
where I want to make sure I don't miss
any H Charlie bodkin the PBS Newshour
stream is better than NBC's okay let me
find that PBS Newshour
sometimes it's hard to find there live
stream PBS live let's take a look here
ah here it is oh good and they actually
they have video inside the room I like
that just so we know we're not missing
it you know here we go very nice okay
good
now it looks like they have these big
orange signs and saying only sit in
these seats it's a sort of social
distancing thing that they are doing in
the in the press briefing room okay good
so we're standing by if you're just
joining us on YouTube remember like the
stream and subscribe it really does help
us out we do have a hypetrain in
progress over on Twitch as well which is
always exciting Mike Jones says work IT
at nursing home with cases no tests
hearing it everywhere Diamond Scout has
subscribed Grandma's Boy says I'm a
mailman working through this what are
your thoughts I don't know you know it
seems to me that if the mail stops that
is problematic even for dealing with
what we're what we're dealing with but
the person who delivers my mail she's
not wearing a mask she's wearing gloves
but she said you know I'm handling all
of this mail and there are different
thoughts about how long it can live on
on cardboard on paper which which
they're handling all the time it's it's
concerning
Caleb Hall says hey David do you know
the logistics behind getting a vaccine
to go from clinical trials and out to
the public any specific idea why it
would take 12 to 18 months even after a
working vaccine yeah so I mean again
this is what from what I've read once
you get to the point where you can have
your first human volunteers the first
tests are merely
not even does the vaccine work is it are
there safety issues or is the vaccine
well tolerated so you've got to get past
that then you need to start testing the
vaccine in different doses to see which
dose triggers the ideal antibody
response but then you've got to measure
that if it triggers an antibody response
for a week and then a month later you no
longer have the antibodies it's not a
very effective vaccine because then
after a month you can get infected again
that's why it's a long process and you
know get for example there's an Israeli
research lab that already had a corona
virus vaccine for poultry before this
started they very quickly modified it
into one that can work in humans but now
they've got to do animal trials than
that then they've got to do the first
human trials it a lot of this is why why
it takes a long time okay let me thank a
few other subscribers on my website
Joanne Kyle Minh is new member number 15
that means we're giving out a third item
today thanks to Phillip a for ordering a
t-shirt on my website Danny Beggan is
new member number 16 at join pakman.com
and Alastair hood is new member number
17 at join pakman.com at 20 we will also
randomly giveaway another t-shirt or
coffee mug from the website looks like
we are getting closer to the start of
this press conference maybe just a few
minutes away at this point in time
Hamiltonian says they say the supply
chain is okay but we've been out three
times over the last few weeks and it's
worse each time no TP dwindling food etc
Hamiltonian I'd be curious where you
live because here in Massachusetts we
experienced that right away but that was
like two weeks ago since people seem to
be much more calm yesterday I went to
the Brookline Trader Joe's they
basically had everything and it wasn't
busy people seem to have slowed down the
panic buying I think places that are
realizing the severity later are having
the panic buying and then hopefully it's
going to be slowing down John Sebastian
Pinera says hey David be honest do you
think Pedro is really from Colombia
he sounds like a troll I think that he
probably at this point I think that that
he probably is a troll we can listen to
that together but I tweeted it earlier
let me see here check this out
tell me tell me what you think of this
guy okay let's go to the phones okay
let's go to the phones a very crazy week
and a lot of people wanting to wanting
to chat the number is six one seven
eight three zero
4750 let's pick up first on our caller
from the 8:06 area code caller from 806
what's your name where you're calling
from today alright is it me yes it is
all Pakman it Pedro from Colombia hola
como estas muy bien you know you know I
had a question for you see cuando me we
have some others in tiempo hace con
tiempo rather speaking you know in
Spanish you know you know I'm trying to
learn I mean not in Spanish about any
English last time you thought that you
were faking you didn't really speak
Spanish but I guess you do oh yeah to
learn English you know I'm just trying
to speak here right now and I get a lot
from watching you mr. Parkman unipro
mandamus in espanol the kiss sudha in
Colombia sauce Oh L capital L capital
anyway you know it's all it's all weird
I don't know what the deal is with this
guy but I mean the thing is he clearly
doesn't have a Colombian accent in
Spanish and it's it's all weird but
increasingly people think that that
that's that's a troll it's it's odd it's
odd okay
Jameson shall be says how do you think
Trump's disastrous response to the
crisis will affect support from a
trumpets and diehard Republicans they
seem to be more supportive of Trump
shockingly somehow it support for Trump
has gone up during this fiasco Bob -
25-ish says I won't vote Trump but I
won't vote DNC when they were losing
they were talking about stealing I'm not
even sure if I trust the results that's
fine you're gonna help Trump get
reelected if you don't care about that
that's fine Cecilia Aaron in has grabbed
the YouTube subscription Sam Rosenberg
says keep up the great work David what
do you think the penalty if any will be
for the Senators found to be selling
stock while lying about kovat I think
the penalty will be nothing tag are Ian
says David the guitar store I work at is
still open
got a close Christopher hellström you
think it was the right decision to close
the schools in America causing parents
having to be at home instead of being in
the hospitals preschools etc listen
they're there every decision has a
downside but can you imagine how much
worse this would be if every school
continued to be open it would be
absolutely insane
hurricane Brenda says thought on ice
arresting kovat 19 patients I mean
listen that's it's like the cherry on
top
what can you even say it's it's it's
just one additional completely crazy
thing that's going on William Scott says
hi David from SMT silicon molding
technologies for all of silicon molding
needs Alex Jones says difference between
collectivism and leftism no boy that
that exceeds the scope of today's stream
Jamal Swift says can you explain the
details of the Fed offering 1.75
trillion to banks earlier this week is
this more corporate corporate social
socialism or am i misunderstanding the
idea is to provide liquidity that the
banks can then use the banks are
tightening up right and the idea is oh
hold on excuse me are things getting out
of control in the chat again because I'm
getting a lot of calls that the
moderators need to wake up remember we
use a light touch conservatism is fine
ignorance is fine but we don't tolerate
we don't tolerate personal attacks hate
speech pseudoscience promoting
pseudoscience cures or anything like
that just keep an eye out guys because
I'm getting a lot of alerts
that we may be we may be losing control
the idea is essentially to to force
banks to provide liquidity is the gist
of it and I've got it I've got a full
segment on it on my youtube channel
Jason Frandsen says I read that we're
doing such little testing that the
positive rate has gone from two to ten
percent so we are increasingly under
estimating the growth rate that may well
be that may well be ng lin has
subscribed on youtube
jamal Swift says one point set a hundred
and seventy five billion annually meant
tristan mcoppins says seems like many
people in the USA and australia are just
business as usual despite possibly
millions of deaths coming what do you
think yeah you know some people there
here's what the thing we have to realize
there is a continued there Zakho Hort
that whenever it ends we'll never have
paid attention and because they didn't
die or go to the hospital they'll
believe it was all overblown those
people we just have to ignore because we
can't do anything about it at some point
if there is a forced lockdown maybe
they'll be affected we need to get work
around them and sadly the problem is
every one of those people means we need
like seven people to be behaving
correctly it's a [ __ ] show
I understand trust me let me say thanks
to Conor Brenner connor is new member
number eighteen today new member number
eighteen at join pakman.com Janet Tucker
is new member number nineteen at join
pakman.com and casey Brinegar is new
member number twenty at join pakman.com
twenty means a fourth free item from the
david pakman show store will be giving
given out to four of these twenty new
members and at twenty five will give out
a fifth item extremely exciting if
you're just joining us we originally
this was scheduled for 12 it was
rescheduled for twelve thirty and now we
are waiting it looks like maybe because
it's saturday we have second stringers
from a lot of the media outlets I don't
see Peter Alexander sitting in this seat
I don't see what's that guy's name John
is it john roberts who normally sits
here
Ellen Collins usually sits in this front
right seat from CNN it looks like this
may be the weekend crew and I don't know
what that will mean in terms of the
caliber of the questions the questions
may be better with the second-stringers
because they may let be less concerned
in general about Trump getting mad at
them I don't know we're going to see
thanks to super zero for the twitch
Prime subscription saying I miss Obama
at least it's not zombies it could all
be always be worse we could be dealing
with coronavirus and zombies Cactus Jack
has subscribed with prime and mr. meow
TV has subscribed with prime I also want
to say thanks to everybody who's sending
super chats and I'm going to continue
answering some of those now okay Jose
Vasquez says what is their justification
for the july/august timeline who knows I
mean honestly at this point everybody's
guessing july-august would be based on
another six weeks of the of increase and
then the beginning of a decline maybe a
lot of this stuff is just guesses right
now jr. Weaver has grabbed the YouTube
subscription pine-sol says my wife is an
RN in Pennsylvania almost out of masks
and gowns Board of Health declining
their covent tests it's happening
everywhere it's it's overwhelming how it
is happening everywhere the president of
Mass General Hospital here in Boston
tweeted or told a reporter two days ago
tell people with 3d printers to download
the plans for printing 3d printing masks
tell them to start printing a friend of
mine who's a doctor here in Boston who's
currently quarantined because he was in
Europe after quarantine he's going back
to work he was on a conference call
where he was told you are going to have
to ration the masks and wear the same
masks all day and he's very worried
about it because normally he would put
on him when you're dealing with
something like this normally you would
put on a mask and then put on the face
plate over it and then you would do your
thing you leave the room you you lift
the face plate throw the
ask out you go into another room with
another patient you put a new mask on
and drop the face plate over it and he's
being told he's going to need to wear
that same mask the the entire time and
that that's not good if you're just
joining us on YouTube please I humbly
ask you to hit like and subscribe we've
had 40,000 different people come on
through the stream so far and only 2,000
have hit like that that's like that's 5%
that's low let's bring that up I think
we could instantly get to 10,000 likes
well not in no that's not true we could
get the 5,000 likes let me put it that
way and people have been asking what's
going on with subscriptions were
actually we're only a hundred
subscribers from eight hundred and
seventeen thousand there's six thousand
people watching if just a few of you hit
that subscribe button we are gonna crush
817 like in so with we could get to
eight hundred and twenty thousand if if
people we're all doing our part by the
way just so people know if when I
mention something about the number of
subscribers you post an anti-semitic
comment in the chat we will ban you we
will ban you because we did we just
don't tolerate that and we have
moderators that they know what to look
for
they know what to look for my friends a
Owens says whoops just missed a whole
bunch of these hold on where did a ones
go a Owens says are you the Dave Rubin
of the left
uh no Thoreau fir Beck says mandatory
quarantine in Bermuda next to a pink
beach thank God for small mercies I
guess but I have horrible survivor guilt
fight on Quinn Reid says our vet
hospitals considered an essential
service that may be a state level
designation I don't know that there's a
federal answer to that
Michael Norman says I do in-home family
therapy in Western Massachusetts and
yesterday I was told to stand up to
yesterday I was told to still have
visits now strongly encouraged to do
telehealth calls yeah my girlfriend's a
psychotherapist and she is doing all
telehealth all telehealth
Angela Lopez sent a three hundred dollar
super chat and retracted the message
Angela
I would have loved to have heard what
you had on your mind with that
incredibly generous contribution of $300
Ali Shaykh says mailman that's sexist oh
boy
breaking news Feinstein and husband sold
5 million of a low down to 27 percent I
did not read that I will investigate for
sure
Dennis borma Straub says myrrh entha
holding trump back again nick Biv sends
a super chat hamiltonian says baltimore
suburbs supply shortage ok lure Epsom
lor a.m. epsom says David's hair
originated in a wet market in Wuhan it
did yeah because it's Saturday see I'll
just do the rest of the stream like this
I think it's fine right I just have to
lower my chair is the only thing there
we go otherwise I'm out of the shot
beautiful all right very good
ok other people to thank I want to say
thanks to a manual Davis whose new
member number 21 today at join
pakman.com James skully is number 22 at
join pakman.com thank you very much very
much appreciate that you can grab a
membership if you please join pakman.com
okay over on twitch let me say thank you
to electric head PT 65 who subscribed
with prime silence has fallen ack
subscribed with prime as well and i
think i already thanked mr. meow
TV as well we we should be just i mean
now we're 10th we're 40 minutes past the
original time for this press conference
and ten minutes past the new time so it
should be starting very very soon thanks
s waverly for the subscription on
youtube Shanee says what is your thought
on the government forcing americans to
stay inside would it make Trump a
dictator someone some say he should
force some say he shouldn't listen I
have a segment on my youtube channel
about this even a shelter-in-place
when we had to remember the a Boston
Marathon
here in Boston when that happened there
was a shelter in place here it was not
enforced by force at the time but people
did it because there were armed
murderers walking around Boston right so
the question of whether it is going to
be a forced thing comes down to
enforcement typically at the state level
oh you could imagine like does the
National Guard get involved but for the
most part like my brothers under shelter
in place in California he's not forced
to stay inside but he's doing it and you
know it the question of force I think is
not even the right one at this point
it's can we even get people to
understand the severity of what's going
on looks like we're about to start as
most of the seats now are are taken Tom
Santiago has grabbed a youtube
subscription that's posed Arizona says
curious to your thoughts as to whether
Fox and others are liable for their
behavior and downplaying the virus and
purposely miss informing the public you
know legal liability would be difficult
but certainly they are morally liable
Nick Biv says David 80% of postal
workers are over 45 years old we will
die some it the Postal Service might
have to get shut down
5:07 performance ends the superjet
Gibble's bits says yang was invited to
Capitol Hill to give a talk about the
benefits of ubi humanity forward is
giving out a million dollars in relief
to New York City residents I did see
that I did see that
Arbuckle says so soon maestro Jay el
colombiano estructure I love it so this
is with with Argentinian conjugation
telling me I'm a teacher and saying the
so-called Colombian is a fake or a troll
martin culver sends a super chat ian
pitchford says keep up the good work
David and it says can we all get a free
blink a subscription if Trump makes no
pronunciation errors in this speech it
was so funny when Trump first went the
day that two days ago Trump the minute
Trump said there are some promising
treatments I immediately said there's no
way he pronounces chloroquine and Ramez
aver correctly
indeed room des aver became mangled into
rum reservoir rum reservoir yeah let's
see here
here in the Netherlands panic vine just
won't stop going on for over a week mom
works in a store people refused to keep
a distance horrible martin culver has
any good websites for hospitalization
stats well the world ah meters does have
this issue of serious or critical you
can assume serious or critical is
hospitalization it's not completely
precise i don't know if at this point we
have anything better especially because
remember that a lot of the people being
hospitalized with presumptive cases
aren't even being tested sometimes
because they don't have okay people are
saying the hair is too much so let me
let me fix it that it's just a
distraction there we go
very good okay sorry about that guys
okay um a lot of people aren't being
tested sometimes because they don't have
tests sometimes because it would not
change the treatment protocol that
that's what we're reading at this point
bob to 25-ish says if you live in purple
vote biden if not don't more EP says i
love you d vacation plans after corona
so right now i have nothing planned
whatsoever i have nothing i cancelled on
wednesday i was supposed to fly to Miami
canceled my flight their canceled my
flight back canceled my hotel in april i
was supposed to go to a conference in
Vegas oh I still have a tough sticking
listen it's not gonna be perfect I'm
sorry I was supposed to go to Vegas in
April that's canceled I am supposed to
appear on the Joe Rogan show soon I'm
not saying exactly when but I don't know
what's gonna happen I'm supposed to
appear with an Joe Rogan's show with
another person and I've been talking to
that person about what are we going to
do and we just don't know we just don't
know yet let me say thank you to crayon
Pandey who is new member number 23 today
Matt Lawson is new member number 24
today
Jakub Radtke is new member number 25
today appreciate that we got 225 let's
go for 50 let's go for 50 why not let's
do it if you're just joining us you
might be confused you might have first
said wasn't this thing scheduled for
noon and yes it originally was then
another duplicate entry showed up at
12:30
for the press briefing and we are now at
12:45 p.m. Eastern time and still
nothing nothing although it seems like
we are getting close if you're joining
on twitch remember to follow my channel
we're almost at 31,000 followers if
you're joining on YouTube please make
sure to LIKE the stream as well as to
subscribe we are where are we we are
just 75 subscribers shy of eight hundred
and seventeen thousand we are
seventy-five shy of rolling over and by
the way we're just I mean who knows why
this hasn't started yet so I'm just I'm
gonna do the equivalent of Trump reading
poll results I will just read subscriber
numbers until they start no I'm kidding
Edward lianca says are the t-shirts
ethically made yes they are where did
that go there there is Caroline Nagle
and Sean Avery have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions as well as Joe Farrell
Alex Jones says do you support banning
private health insurance I don't because
I think that it is there's no point in
banning private health insurance develop
a good-enough system and people will
just move away from it I think that
legally it is going to be very difficult
in the u.s. to do that it'll become a
distraction it'll become the focus of
the battle I don't think it's it's a
battle worth having let people just go
away from it because there's a better
alternative the problem will take care
of itself natural phenomenon says thank
you for covering all this I trust your
objectivity and love your adorable boom
Ernest keep up the good work oh dear
John Butler has subscribed Joe
Millionaire sends a super chat M Gray
says when will we get more shirtless
pictures you know the shirtless pictures
of me are going to be only on Instagram
and they are going to be few and far
between
let me see when the last one was on my
Instagram it's been a while it's been a
while yeah I can't even find the latest
shirtless picture on Instagram
okay yesterday's conference was my
favorite one I don't know that it was my
favorite one
Helen Danielson has grabbed a youtube
subscription Mike Wu says do you feel
this will give more steam to research
marijuana and hemp not saying it's a
cure but some studies say it helps with
lung capacity
I don't know that smoking anything ever
helps with lung capacity there is
information that not only smokers but
vapors are doing worse when they get
coronavirus and I would never suggest to
anyone in my audience that they put any
smoke or quote vape into their lungs
you know vape is presented as this very
benign thing it's vape vape means vapor
it's like breathing in steam in a sauna
no they are aerosolized chemicals and
there's every indication that it is very
bad to be putting that stuff in your
lungs
maybe not worse than cigarettes okay but
it's not good anybody who's shocked by
the way that aerosolizing chemicals into
your lungs might be bad I don't know
what to tell you new member number 26
today is Jason divot Jason divot
Brittany H is new member number 27 Thank
You Brittany very much appreciate that
we will give away another t-shirt or
coffee mug at 30 new members where we
are just three away from that okay we
really should be close to getting
started here I I apologize for the delay
as if it has anything to do with me
Thoreau fir Beck says what do you think
about the morality of shorting the
market when this was starting regardless
of insider info it's you know I I that's
a mechanism I I think we have far more
immorality than saying I perceive that
the market will go down I'm going to
short it I'm not operating on any public
information on any inside information
I'm not gonna go crazy about people who
did that I didn't do it the only move
that the Finance
the moves I've made since these
implosions have started are I've
accelerated my purchase of index funds
just wat broad-based index funds I've
started buying a little bit more
I bought Live Nation stock Live Nation
none of these are financial suggestions
please by the way actually you know what
I shouldn't even really do this
let me not even do it okay
JAC Qadam says yesterday's conference
was one for the books how many elements
of medical do you think they've ordered
as of today what would Trump's uncle say
I don't know John Trump is a genius
Guillermo Gomez jr. says I could be
wrong but notice Trump was the only one
during yesterday's briefing that called
it the Chinese virus wonder how their
meetings go oh yeah I would love other
reporters today to say to the other
people why aren't you calling it the
Chinese virus the president who's
running this entire [ __ ] show is calling
it a Chinese virus why aren't you
calling it a Chinese virus I think that
that would be interesting and I'm
curious how they would open pay oh did
call it that sorry guys yeah very thank
you for fact-checking me Pompeyo did
indeed call it that Kelly Dee says if
you don't mind could you say what to you
is hantai Semitic I mean versus being
critical of Israel please don't take me
wrong being critical of Israel has
nothing to do with anti-semitism with
the very small exception that there are
people who fail their anti-semitism as
criticism of Israel believe me nothing
that's getting the banhammer dropped in
the chat has anything to do with Israel
Stewart Keating says will we get any
nasty questions remarks by him today
probably Christopher hellström says
parents being home how is this affecting
hospital staff I don't I don't have the
numbers unfortunately we have reached
and surpassed 7,000 viewers on YouTube
and 1,600 over on Twitch the combined
viewership right now is right around
9,000 across all platforms and growing
interest growing interest ladies and
gentlemen and what we are what we are
soon to hear from Donald
I think also quite frankly guys people
just being home is making it so that the
live streams are doing doing better and
better remember don't just watch you got
a like and subscribe if you're on
YouTube and make sure to follow if
you're on Twitch let me thank some
people on Twitch Leicester Kovacs has
subscribed with twitch Prime that's
funny Leicester Kovacs is the my fake
name I use when I order delivery Papa
smoke six seven seven six has also
subscribed with twitch Prime which I
very much appreciate twitch Prime is a
big big deal let me say thanks to
Jennifer McCartney whose new member
number twenty eight today at join
pakman.com Jennifer thank you so
appreciate your support
Brent Hess says the like button isn't
visible on android youtube is that right
let me pull up my own stream on an
that's interesting maybe it's hard to
actually even know how to like and
subscribe if you're on certain okay so
here's my stream whoops now i'm on a
delay that's a good where is the like
button oh you have to X out live chat
live chat when you open my stream on
Android covers the like button so you've
got an ex out live chat then you like
which I just did and then you hit
subscribe and then you hit the bell oh
my god there's so much to do so much to
do Seth Barham says weapon of choice if
the virus mutates and we get zombies you
know what I think the weapon of choice
would be colloidal silver and I'm
kidding but on that note we're releasing
this on Wednesday here is what we wait
here's just a compilation of some of the
grifters around coronavirus god gave us
this product yeah I believe yes how many
did we go Veronica was he gave this to
us about 10 12 years ago and we have it
at our home we have it in cases remember
why wouldn't God just prevent
coronavirus instead of giving us
coronavirus and then giving us Silver
scams we use it all the time I have this
and
I mean I don't think I'd have made it
without silver when I made it it for my
throat in all that absolutely and this
is amazing why whatever so so would you
recommend is a doctor people to have
silver in there an Oscar it's a
naturopath okay doctor suggests that
this is a medical doctor it's not you
never want to be without silver now so
many reasons never never you know this
is a staple top yes stated I think this
is a staple for your family
yeah right and we can talk more about it
maybe we have more time than ever all I
can say is that it has been proven by
the government which government that it
has the ability to kill every pathogen
it has ever been tested on which ones
has it been tested on was it in a petri
dish that's very different than in-situ
including SARS and HIV eight seven seven
seven eight nine two five three not on
this Tuesday global transmission I'm not
gonna belabor this I'm just gonna tell
you that versus your daily life and your
gums and your teeth and for regular
viruses and bacteria the patented nano
silver we have the Pentagon has come out
and documented and Homeland Security had
said this stuff kills the whole SARS
coronal at point-blank range kills every
right every virus dies when you when you
use the toothpaste now what if the virus
is in your lungs
you have to aspirate the toothpaste to
get it into the lungs
we don't know uh-huh but it's the thing
they found that and then this is this is
thirteen years ago right and the
Pentagon uses the product we have and
the product we have and private label
can you imagine the Pentagon is placing
orders from Alex Jones's store is about
to be in Walmart coming up they just
ordered a massive crap-ton of that not
the one they have but this even better
one that we have yeah so I'm just saying
we're always cutting edge thank to God
by the way this is up this is a preview
we're publishing this is part of our
grifter compilation that we're
publishing Monday I just I just go with
the research go with the spirit and we
always have it then the nano silver
toothpaste in the super blue with the
tea tree and
tea tree and silver the iodine that's a
super blue is amazing then we have the
whitening toothpaste that has the nano
silver and a lot more as well
those are both X 1/3 and for short comm
basically the silver will kill
coronavirus and whiten your teeth while
you're at it will discount despite all
the hell breaking loose
we have squirtable food in stock but we
have to package it and it's six to eight
weeks behind shipping it out to you
other people will lie to you the big old
Pinocchio noses we're not that's what's
going on you want storable food you want
to get delivered this thing of it is
super bad beeps in about 12 weeks in the
u.s. the models show so you'll get your
food in for store.com and it's high
quality it's very low price they haven't
raised prices yet but I'm told it's next
week
yeah 24 store.com put your hand on that
television yes Jesus thank you Lord
Jesus
he received your hailing yes this is the
stuff of like this would be in an
apocalyptic zombie movie this would be
part of it now say it I'll take it
so what's on his hand it's like is that
holy water mine it's mine I thank you
and praise you for it
yes and I forgive if I have aught
against any writer and I praise you that
I'm well and hold I praise you that I'm
according to the Word of God I'm healed
yes and I consider not my own body this
guy's worth 760 million dollars
I consider not symptoms in my body I
consider not symptoms but only that
which God has promised only bad what the
word has said by His stripes I was
healed and by His stripes I am healed
now I'm not the sick trying to get
healed
I'm the heat there you go guys he's just
been cured of coronavirus we're still
standing by for Trump don't worry we're
not gonna miss it he'll then The Devil's
trying to give me the flu
train or whatever else kind of whatever
try
yeah he'll and well yes in a sweet
neighborhood this is a lung disease so
the healthier your lungs are the better
your chance it doesn't mean you won't
get infected but you can battle the
virus better smokers are extremely
vulnerable vapors are not doing well but
if you have that's actually not true
there was an article about a medical
study that showed that vaping the
whatever propofol something chloride in
a vape is actually preventing people
from getting the propylene glycol is
proven they also have other side effects
I don't think therapy what we want to
shoot god I feel the holy spirit go word
of God
yeah I'm sensing something as well the
Lord is gonna honor our prayers and let
me say from the beginning of being a
Bible student with a hundred and seventy
thousand hours of study Hebrew words
Greek words Jewish history Israel
history parallels of history just to be
clear this guy's not Jewish okay there's
just a lot of these evangelical nuts
they consider themselves Jewish scholars
as well prophetic parallels that if this
were just a man-made virus and they've
call it an evolutionary virus or doesn't
matter what it is if it were just a
normal thing then if we pray and repent
it would immediately be stopped right if
it was a normal thing it's not that now
if it is a permitted thing
meaning the hand of the Lord came off
the country for the abominations right
and you got to read the Bible guys to
understand this won't make sense then
there's nothing we can do except pray
and ask God to help us repent and we're
talking about national repentance is
right we're helpless other than prayer
okay looks like we're about to get
started here so we'll close this out
very very good we'll see which one of
these streams has the loudest volume
sometimes the streams are a little are a
little bit quiet welcome if you're just
joining us we've been standing by for an
hour we've got Ben Carson
we've got Anthony foul G we've got the
Admiral as he is known don't recognize
this guy or this guy but we'll see how
it all goes down let me say thanks to
Jason stick Jason stick is new member
number 29 today Carol otter Strom is new
member number 30 at join pakman.com
Steve Walker thanks Steve
new member number 31 at join pakman.com
and I think that's everybody yeah thank
you very much appreciate your support
here is Donald Trump and pence
thank you very much a lot of things
going on and we're gonna be going over
to the hill and there were a lot of
meetings and from the financial this is
a medical situation not a financial
situation that Akali a potential though
is moving along very nicely I wanna
thank you for being here let me just see
if the level is better over here oh this
is like way behind all right we'll just
stick in our war against the virus
governor's mayor's the businesses
charities and citizens are all working
with urgency and speed toward one common
goal which is saving American lives were
in communication with foreign countries
it's now at 148 foreign countries can
you believe that 100 you talk about us
so we can believe about a violent spread
148 countries not even believable
there's been a week of national action
and of great national solidarity people
are getting along we're getting along
with Republicans and Democrats and
independents and liberals and
conservatives and actually it's a very
nice thing to see we're all one
beautiful big American family and that's
taking place right now last night I
approved a major disaster declaration
for the state of New York I worked very
closely with Governor Cuomo and is the
first time in our nation's history that
a presidents used the Stafford act to
declare a major disaster in response to
a public health crisis never happened
before and considering other areas where
we may or may not be doing that and
working very closely with Gavin Newsom
governor of California and others we may
be doing the same thing depending on
their needs depending on what they are
asking for it's been unprecedented
action in New York and we've had a
tremendous federal response all over the
country
and I want to thank all the people in
the federal government and obviously in
the state governments and local
governments we are working hard
everybody is working hard and the people
standing alongside of me are working
very hard that I can tell you we've also
reached agreements with Canada and
Mexico on new travel rules at our
northern and southern borders to halt
the entry of the Chinese virus well
continuing trade and commerce and we've
had very good talks I've with Prime
Minister Trudeau and today this morning
with President Lopez Obrador
and they talked about joint measures
that were taken to prevent the spread of
the virus in our countries and to
temporarily suspend non-essential travel
we had a great conversation this morning
president of Mexico and our close
cooperation with Mexico and Canada will
keep our people healthy keep their
people healthy keep everybody safe
yesterday I had a call with 12,000 small
businesses representatives of these
businesses that's the engine of our
country people don't realize that you
know you really love people getting ones
but these small business when you add
them up together is a really the engine
economic engine of our country and I
assured them that my administration is
doing everything within it's very
considerable considerable power frankly
to support them and their employees
nobody's ever done what we've done
likewise I had calls during the week
with all sorts of representatives and
systems like the hospital system we
spoke to many of the hospital systems
throughout the country nurses and
doctors representatives representing
hundreds of thousands of nurses and
doctors airlines and cruise ship
companies the Business Roundtable which
was fully attended and it's all of the
top CEOs of of our country and beyond
frankly the businessmen of they should
get directly to the medical world a
world Scyld business Ben these are
has been that control the biggest
companies in the world
mr. Schmidt many of them have taken hits
and many of them are just you know going
forward that they've got their
businesses have been have been great
some have been very badly affected some
of it affected it all and frankly some
or doing very well they continue to do
very well it's Walmart as an example has
been really helpful to us
shocking Walmart Dillon the head of
Walmart really helpful to us and I guess
I assume they're doing pretty well
because people is certainly buying buy
more and more than even a clip at oh
yeah this has been great economically
members fantastic for a while doing
incredibly they put on tremendous extra
staff you don't have empty shelves a lot
of things have happened that are very
good restaurants fast food executives
grocery stores all retailers literally
all of them in groups and we spoke with
the g7 leaders at length as you know you
probably know about that yeah spoke to
many of the governors spoke almost all
of the governors at conference calls and
many of the governors individually and
very importantly the religious leaders
we had a great Oh super important yeah
yesterday the vice president and myself
with the religious leaders have got to
be kidding me
of our country many of the religious
leaders and we've had a number of them
during the course of the last two weeks
actually but yesterday we had a very
very significant call with the religious
leaders of our country I signed
legislation providing American workers
with paid sick leave and paid family
medical leave had no cost to employers
and free testing for those who need it
the testings going very well in the
Ethel I speak to that along with Tony
we're working quickly to pass additional
legislation that will provide massive
relief to small businesses and affected
industries and give direct payments to
our great workers and hard-working
American families has never been
anything like we're doing on the hill
right now they're negotiating Mitch
McConnell Chuck Schumer they're all up
there Kevin McCarthy
and Nancy Pelosi they're all negotiating
and everybody's working hard and they
want to get to a a solution that's the
right solution I think we're getting
very close we've also announced that
we've moved tax day from April 15th
through July 15th which is a big deal
giving businesses and individuals extra
time to file and pay without interest or
penalties so we've moved the date way
back and so it'll be July 15th instead
of your traditional April 15th and very
importantly you will have a lot of time
but you're not going to have interest
penalties or any kind of penalties by
filing at that later date HUD announced
that foreclosures and evictions are
suspended for several family home owners
with FHA insured mortgages for the next
60 days and a great head of HUD who's
with us today Ben Carson's going to say
a few words in a moment that'll be a
part of Education will not enforce
standardized testing which is another
big deal requirements for students in
elementary through high school for the
current school year not fair to do that
so we we are waiving that I'm I would
imagine it's probably the first time
ever that's been waived but I think it's
only fair to the students and to the
parents of the students it is also
waiving interest and other things that
we're discussing right now thing on
federally held student loans and
directed that borrowers be allowed to
suspend their student loan payments
without penalty for at least 60 days and
we'll be talking about student loans can
I have the students they're under a
great burden right now so so we can do
something about those loans we're we're
waving during this 60-day period various
elements and very important elements on
student loans big subject I signed an
executive order invoking the defense
production act as you all know giving us
powerful new authorities to help state
cities and hospitals for cure needed
supplies there's been a clear call to
action
to the private sector and the call is
made right here it's been really pretty
amazing what's happened with the private
sector they are really in sixth gear I
think which is responded in full force
helping to produce and supply
much-needed masks swabs sanitizers
ventilators and everything else is is a
move on that's incredible right now and
by way of example Haines everybody knows
Haines great company great consumer
cotton products company is retrofitting
its manufacturing capabilities in large
sections of their plants to produce
masks and they're in that process right
now then in my direction the FDA has
taken rapid steps to make these items
available for medical use right now I
mean most excitingly to me is what the
FDA has done in order to get possibly a
very successful number it's not just one
or two number of therapeutics medicines
that can help help people that are
already sick help people not get sick
then obviously buddy without the vaccine
and Tony will discuss that a little bit
later but the vaccine is moving along
but this is something that right now for
right now if this is what we really it's
incredible and what the FDA has done and
dr. Stephen Hahn was highly respected
came as a just a highly respected man
he's been fantastic great guy he's only
been here for a couple of months and
he's he's gotten thrown into the swim of
it and he's really standing up but the
FDA has really moved to mountains I said
it this morning they moved mountains to
get approvals on things that that may be
work we'll find out very soon and we'll
take long an example of the pair no
Ricard
which is God he was really an example
where we're repurposing alcohol they
went out and repurposed their alcohol
production capabilities in Arkansas
Kentucky Texas and West Virginia to make
hand sanitizer
it's a big difference and they've been
unbelievable they really pernod ricard
their first delivery will be on Tuesday
it's going to go to various states
they're gonna start I think in New York
and they're gonna work their way around
they're making a tremendous amount of
hand sanitizer at a very high level too
by the way extremely high level
sanitizers activated the National
Response Coordination Center - level 1
that's your highest level
there's the nerve center of all of our
government response to crisis and it's
coordinating very closely with our
nation's governor's our nation's
governor's many of you were at the call
yesterday with the governors and I think
you can see the relationship and we've
had numerous calls with governor's by
the way but the relationships are pretty
amazing they like they're loving what
we're doing and the coordination between
the federal government and the
governor's states and even local has
been pretty incredible it sounds like
things are great guys - Pete Gaynor who
is with us will soon be providing you
with an update on the center's
operations and FEMA's been incredible we
got them involved last week for a much
involved another involved nationwide
we've dramatically expanded telehealth
so Americans can see a doctor without
leaving home something which more and
more people are using and now they're
really using it and now the ones that
are using it or loving it and I think
we're gonna change the way everybody's
functions medically and probably in
other ways because of what's going on
right now this will reduce the chance of
infection and preserve hospital capacity
so it sells a lot of problems every
American is a role to play in defending
our nation from this invisible horrible
enemy it really is it's an invisible
enemy the invisible scourge cessful very
successful hopefully very much sooner
than people would even think so we say
stay at home and save lives there's a
time of shared national sacrifice but
it's also a time to treasure our loved
ones
and to take stock of what is most
important our faith our families our
neighbors in our great country and I
want to thank all of the incredible
people of our country the citizens of
our country that what you've done and
the way you're responding is to have the
country starting a very special
something that we will never forget that
the history books will never forget then
we're gonna have a great victory we're
gonna be celebrating a great victory in
the not-too-distant future and I just
want to thank everybody and now we're
gonna celebrate it's only thirty
thousand people died vice president Mike
Pence has led the task force and I will
tell you this he has not slept much
maybe a tiny bit maybe a little bit but
not much and he's done an incredible job
Mike thank you please thanks to the
incredible leadership of the president
good afternoon all and Thank You mr.
president
the White House coronavirus task force
met today we briefed the president on
our latest recommendations we continue
at the president's direction and to lead
not a whole-of-government approach but a
whole of America approach you just heard
the president describe one inspiring
story after another at the way the
American people are responding the way
American businesses are responding
religious communities across this
country those pastors people are coming
together they're responding with common
sense compassion and generosity people
are heeding the advice of state and
local authorities and tens of millions
of Americans are putting into practice
15 days to slow the spread we are we are
officially mr. president it's six days
into our 15 days and as we look all
across this country feels like money
while we we strongly support the
decisions that governors in states where
we have
[ __ ] outbreak had taken we encourage
every American to listen to those state
and local authorities for every American
this is what you can do to make a
difference over the next week and a few
days to protect your health protect your
family's health but most especially slow
the spread and the potential for the
coronavirus to impact the most
vulnerable as the president said we
we've been we've almost been overwhelmed
at the other winning of support from
American businesses the president spoke
yesterday to thousands of small
businesses we spoke to manufacturers
yesterday and in fact as the president
indicated the FDA in in record time just
approved one manufacturer that will be
producing millions of surgical masks in
a matter of weeks for the American
people didn't 35 million guests and we
want to thank all the religious leaders
from every community of faith in the
country making a hard choice to suspend
services to have online services even
while those ministries are continuing to
support food banks and come alongside of
the most vulnerable and of course the
chorus of prayers that is coming up from
communities of faith around the country
is making the difference that it always
has in the life of this nation one thing
the president and I promised was to
remind people that on the the weekends
that you're not in the pews it's still
the good it's still a good idea too if
you can to go ahead and make that
donation continue because all the
ministries are considered churches role
in our communities their plan is
donating to your church the President
and I are grateful that the American
people are listening to state and local
authorities and and putting into
practice all of all of the
recommendations in the president's
coronavirus guidelines and as you will
hear in just a few moments from Admiral
Gua testing is expanding rapidly across
the United States of America state-run
drive-throughs are expanding across the
country and as you will hear detail this
morning
more than a hundred and ninety-five
thousand Americans and more who have
been symptomatic have been tested that
number does not include County hospitals
or or healthcare labs around the nation
some 15,000 in number
OKC among the number of the more than a
hundred ninety five thousand that have
been tested it's important to remember
that only nineteen thousand three
hundred and forty three at this moment
have tested positive for the corona
virus we want to we continue to urge
state and local health authorities to
contact FEMA for all the latest
developments and innovations in testing
but we want to remind Americans as dr.
Fauci will emphasize in a moment if you
don't have symptoms don't do a test it
is another way that the American people
can make sure that we are preserving the
resources that our health care workers
need to minister and to support those
who are dealing with the corona virus
and other illnesses in a moment
Pete Gaynor will detail the efforts at
FEMA since the president's national
emergency declaration we have FEMA in
the lead stood up the National Response
Coordination Center as the president
said and we are working close with a
literally hour by hour through FEMA
processing requests from states most
impacted like New York Washington State
and California and will continue and to
work very very closely with those states
through the very traditional means of
federal emergency management at FEMA
secretary Carson will describe decisive
actions the president alluded to to
bring foreclosure relief to Americans
and on the subject of supplies in a
moment you will hear of not only the
progress that we're making on testing
but on Monday we'll be detailing for the
American people the progress that we are
making on the president's strategy of
procuring more personal protective
equipment and medical supplies
allocating them through the system of
FEMA and continuing to urge the
conservation by Americans in fact I'm
pleased to report
to the president today that HHS just
placed an order for hundreds of millions
of n95 masks that will be being made
available to us every day we're told
about orders being placed and yet every
day hospitals have none all for
Americans to postpone elective medical
procedures including dental services and
remember this is another way that you're
going to make sure that medical supplies
are available because by postponing
elective medical procedures you're
freeing up medical supplies for those
dealing with the coronavirus as the
president mentioned our team is on
Capitol Hill as we speak working with
members of Congress in both political
parties they're making progress
by all accounts on a bipartisan bill
they worked late into the night last
night it started early this morning and
we are working to pass that legislation
on Monday in both the House and the
Senate now on a personal note many of
you may have been made aware that a
member of my staff has tested positive
for the corona virus right we learned of
that late yesterday I am pleased to
report that he is doing well he had mild
cold like symptoms for about a day and a
half has not been to the White House
since Monday neither the president nor I
had direct contact with that staff
person we worked immediately with a
White House physician and the CDC we've
done all contact tracing and while the
White House doctor is indicated that he
has no reason to believe that I was
exposed and no need to be tested given
the unique position that I have is Vice
President and as the leader of the White
House coronavirus task force yeah both I
and my wife will be tested for the
corona virus later this afternoon huh
let me say again how grateful the
President and I are that every American
has acted on the president's coronavirus
guidelines we are six days into 15 days
oh the fact that as doctor foul she may
well reflect in a moment is an
opportunity for us here on the foot
holes of this epidemic curve in our
country to literally lower the impact in
our nation and save lives every American
can do their part
to slow the spread and we encourage you
to continue to do that as the president
says often remember we're all in this
together
and also remember that that for for most
Americans their risk of serious illness
from the coronavirus the Maine's luck
remains low the reason we want to put
into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines is because no
American would want to inadvertently
expose someone who is vulnerable a
senior with a serious underlying health
condition to the corona virus with a
potential threat I did hear one story
this morning mr. president about a
senior great story named genival wood
she actually is at the Life Care Center
in Kirkland Washington she is not only a
grandmother she is a great-great
grandmother 90 years young and she
tested positive for the corona virus on
March 6 what a great story
by all accounts she's doing well and she
wanted America know there is hope and
her strength and her enthusiasm it's
truly an inspiration to the nation as
the president said many times we're
gonna get through this you come out
stronger than ever before and we'll get
through this as Americans together Thank
You mr. president giving thanks Mike
thank you
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president as I told you earlier last
week we are in the process and are
effectively transitioning to large-scale
testing by leveraging all the components
of the American healthcare system
this guy says this never doubted it was
CDC only then it was the state public
health laboratories now we're
transitioning into the mainstream of
American testing with many of the
companies that the president invited in
the Rose Garden just a week ago so
currently 91 public health laboratories
state public health laboratories are up
and running in 50 states the District of
Columbia Guam and Puerto Rico
this is our curve and I want to be very
clear about this that this only accounts
for CDC state public health laboratories
and the laboratories that are members
the American Clinical Laboratory
Association these are the main reference
laboratories LabCorp Quest Mayo Europe
bio reference labs in sonic healthcare
it does not account for the well over
10,000 15,000 hospital based labs many
of which are doing testing for whom we
will get data this week to give you an
overall roll of one hundred ninety five
thousand people in America have
completed their testing that means tests
plus results this does not count the
people whose tests are in process and as
you see this curve is going it will
continue to rise dramatically over the
next period of time so again this is
utilizing all the components of the
great American healthcare system the
state and local public health
laboratories the hospital system which
is not represented here and the main
reference laboratories we're getting
close to testing point oh one percent of
the population we're getting dangerously
close she will definitely emphasize this
more there are priorities for testing
and clearly everyone across the country
should understand that those
hospitalized are in an ICU or a priority
for testing symptomatic health care
workers for obvious reasons we want to
make sure that they their health is
preserved and that they are not going to
spread to those who may be seriously ill
symptomatic people and long-term care
facilities as the vice-president is
highlighted and we've said many times
elderly in our society have a much
higher mortality rate much higher
serious complication rate symptomatic
individuals over 65 symptomatic
individuals who have underlying
conditions like chronic heart disease or
liver disease or other types of chronic
diseases patients and public health
investigations and there are local
priorities around the country
particularly health care workers for
testing and doctor foul she's gonna
emphasize this about the types of people
who may not be to be tested testing is
going well it's ramping up but we should
still have pre or testing testing
finally I want to talk about the
community-based testing sites I know
they're popular now because you know
there's now an acronym which I'm sure
the vice-president doesn't appreciate
CBTs
or CBT sites we talked about these
earlier in the week and why doesn't want
it to like again that these are state
managed and locally executed the federal
government is there to provide support
know-how blue plant blueprints on how to
do this but these are really springing
up at dozens and dozens of sites all
over the country adapted to the local
needs some are drive through the summer
walk up some are geared to health care
workers and emergency responders so
again what we see in the upcoming week
is this curve will continue to increase
as testing becomes more widely available
as the great American healthcare
industry continues to increase the
availability of tests and the throughput
of those tests
let's here's some actual science and our
president mr. vice president what I want
to do just over the next minute or so is
maybe connect some of the dots of the
things that you've heard today first the
status of the dynamics of the of the
outbreak I mean you all know the numbers
you've seen them we have widespread
infection but to varying degrees
throughout the country so for example
when you talk about the kinds of
mitigation issues that we have put forth
and have emphasized just as I mentioned
the other day there are two dynamic
forces that are going on at the same
time you're having the natural course of
an outbreak trying to peak at a high
level and then you have the mitigation
strategies which are aimed at dampening
that we've mentioned that multiple times
we often get asked how do you know
you're having an effect because there
are two things that are going on at the
same time they may be confounding well I
can tell you for sure from a public
health standpoint and experience with
other outbreaks we know we are clearly
having an effect but we can't quantitate
it for you accurately now because
looking forward you'll know what the
impact of the rate of this steep
inclines will be so that's what we're
gonna come back to you every day and
keep you up to date about that getting
with regard to the disproportionate of
the response everyone is right here I'll
get the
open up the vice president's book with
his permission this is baseline for
everyone in other ways throughout the
country but then there will be areas and
you've heard them Washington State
California New York City in which the
the the dynamics of the outbreak are
clearly different and much more robust
if you want to use that word and that's
the reason why we seen the mitigation
ratcheted up in that regard and again
hopefully and I and I have confidence it
will happen you will see an impact on
that next getting to testing you saw the
the numbers with testing remember there
was always an issue with testing I think
we're getting to the solution that
everybody in the country is looking for
but I want to emphasize one thing that
Admiral Jawa mentioned is that not every
single person in the United States needs
to get tested he gave you the priorities
I don't want to repeat them but let me
tell you one of the unintended
consequences of individuals who don't
need to get tested that flood the desire
to get tested currently and I hope
you'll be able to change it and make it
much less reliable on PPEs when you go
in and get tested you are consuming
personal protective equipment masks and
gowns those are high priority for the
healthcare workers who were taking pair
of people who have cooked a corona virus
disease so what we don't want to do is
to have a situation where we will we do
have disparities and availability of
ppes now and we're working hard to
correct that but currently today we want
to make sure that the people who are
taking care of people with coronavirus
disease do not endanger themselves
because they don't have the personal
protective equipment and then finally
one last thing was just mentioned the
Surgeon General has been pushing this
please put off canceled elective medical
and surgical procedures you don't want
to not ever do them but for the time
being don't do them because they also
not only consume personal protective
equipment they may also consume
some of the things like ventilators that
you might need so let's pull in this
together and we will get through it I
promise you thank you thank you mr.
president mr. vice president FEMA is now
leading the federal operation all the
federal response for all operations on
behalf of the White House core Nevarez
task force who oversees this whole of
nation response is the Boston yeah HHS
will continue to provide their expert
matter expertise on health and pursuant
to the nationwide
emergency declaration FEMA in
coordination with HHS Rhode Island
system state local tribal territorial
governments and their other eligible
entities with health and safety
emergency protective measures on behalf
of the American public as of yesterday
50 states the District of Columbia five
territories and one tribe are working
directly with FEMA under the nationwide
emergency declaration for covin 19 in
just 24 hours we've obligated a hundred
million dollars to States territories
and tribes a little bit about supplies
it is of the utmost importance that
requests for assistance especially for
critical supplies get routed through
proper channels as soon as possible we
asked everyone to follow the normal
procedures the normal procedures FEMA
uses in a natural disaster there's no
different procedure for the Cova 19 hand
emic but remember you can still order
supplies from your regular vendors and
buy it on the open market
buy it where you can find it we will
reimburse you if you buy medical
supplies from foreign sources it is
reimbursable by America does not apply
to the Stafford Act except for
Washington DC and Puerto Rico if you
can't buy it on the open market make a
request through the FEMA system request
for assistance at the local and county
level should first go to States from
States to the regional FEMA offices and
then from those offices right here in DC
where the National Response Coordination
Center is open and running we are
getting requests for mass PPE swab sets
test site supports ventilators hospital
capacity assessments and many more we
are in lockstep with HHS to answer these
requests
but we will do whatever is necessary to
get States tribes territories and others
they what they need and then finally
what we are doing here in Washington DC
again this is a whole-of-government
response like all emergencies response
is most successful when it is locally
executed state managed and fairly
supported we can't say that enough
on Thursday our federal partners fully
integrated with our National
Coordination Response Coordination
Center and additionally all ten FEMA
regions across the country have been
activated the FEMA regional
administrators will continue to
coordinate closely with governor's state
of emergency managers state public
health officials to determine the type
and level of support needed to respond
to this dynamic threat Ben you tell us a
little something oh thank you mr.
president and mr. vice president for
your tireless leadership here but I also
want to thank the fellow Task Force
members who have been working around the
clock I'm a very patriotic way to serve
their fellow Americans you know part of
the American dream is having a home and
sometimes people say well what is
housing help do it health it has
everything to do with health having a
safe home and that is the reason that
the president has authorized the
immediate cessation of foreclosure and
eviction proceedings for American
citizens single family forward mortgages
as well as reverse mortgages and as you
know FHFA has also decided to do the
same thing for 60 days and the CFPB is
very happy with all this as well and
it's really all about helping our people
recognizing that they're being severely
impacted by the chronovisor
virus and we've also asked the various
services of mortgage loans
to exercise forbearance for anybody
who's having difficulty it is important
if you're having difficulty to actually
contact the people who have made the
loan who established the mortgage
because it doesn't happen automatically
what does happen automatically is that
we cover all eight point five million
people in terms of the moratorium on
foreclosures and all boys we want also
for the PHAs to be protected HUD does
not have authority to mandate that
evictions can occur but we are in
contact with all the PHAs across the
country and our petitioning Congress for
the power to be able to actually enforce
that but the fact of the matter is most
of the PHAs are run by people who
actually care about other people so we
really had I've seen much of a problem
there we haven't seen much of a problem
with forbearance and needing to try to
force people to do it because they want
to do it people are stepping up and
saying what can we do to be helpful as
far as Housing Choice Voucher section 8
is concerned that April vouchers will be
sent out next week and may volunteers
are already being worked on and we were
also staying in contact with all the
stakeholders the advocates for
low-income housing as well as other
stakeholders to make sure that we're
doing things that are most helpful to
them and additionally we've extended the
deadlines for healthcare and
multi-family financial reporting
requirements and that's for over 20,000
multifamily and health care borrowers
until April the 30th and that provides
them with a lot more flexibility to do
with the issues that they're dealing
with I also want to thank our FHA
Commissioner Brian Montgomery as well as
the FHFA director mark Calabria and
Kathy can enjoy the director of the CFPB
who've all worked tirelessly with us to
make this happen what we're trying to do
is bridge the gap recognizing that it's
a lot easier for us to take these
measures and for Congress to take the
measures that they're taking so that we
don't destroy a very excellent system
and have to start all over again so for
those who are worried about the money
that's being spent if you don't spend
the money and deal with this now it's
kind of cost a whole lot more to try to
build all this up again and as was
mentioned by the president there's been
a sense of unity that we haven't seen
for a long time in this country and
let's hope and pray that that unity last
far beyond this crisis right and keep
donating to churches penn said thank you
very much if you've lost your job now or
you're worried that you're gonna lose
your job tomorrow restaurant something
like that what do you want people to do
immediately the second question sir you
heard from the vice president that he's
gonna be tested are you already or
they're worried that they're about to
lose it tomorrow and said what do you
want them to do right well what they do
right now is keep receiving their
paycheck and hopefully their companies
are gonna be in a very strong position
we want they're not everything together
people laid off so we think we're gonna
have a tremendous bounce-back
now some people agree with that very
strongly some of our top economists say
think we're gonna have a very once we
solve the problem of that we're working
on the medical problem so we want them
to keep their jobs stay where you are
and we'll see what happens now if they
don't we have unemployment we have
checks we have a lot of things
happening a lot of very positive things
nobody has ever done no this is working
with Democrats as Republicans and
Democrats and myself working together
nobody's ever done a package like this
it's a great package but ideally we want
them to be able to keep their jobs keep
the pay coming and I think that's gonna
happen Kelly go ahead mr. president on
your defense production act power one of
the features of that is that the federal
government would be able to control the
output whether it's masks or ventilators
go get it to the most areas of need and
control the pricing to keep it at a
market level so it's not price gouging
one of the things we're hearing from
governors they can't find supplies and
prices have gone up
so you've talked about the answer but
you have not yet compelled any companies
why not
because we have so many companies making
so many products every product that you
mentioned plus ventilators and
everything else we have car companies
without having to use the act if we
don't have to use specifically we have
the act to use in case we need it but we
have so many things being made right now
by so many they've just stepped up in
fact Mike Pence and I were discussing it
before we've never seen anything like it
where they are volunteering we want to
make masks for Mike Haynes oh I brought
that up as an example General Motors I
bring that up is another Ford itself
right they're going they're going to go
in the open market we want them on the
open market from a standpoint of pricing
because otherwise it's gonna be we could
be very unfair to the places in greatest
need we are directing States and
sometimes we'll be competing against
states which I don't want to do this
thing I don't want to do we want the
states to go first and you know what
we're doing is we're helping States
that's what we want to do same thing
with the testing we're helping States
we're helping States get to where they
want I negotiated this progress in every
aspect of what happens today well it's
happening fast right now and the
governors are out there trying to get
and if they are competing with us we
immediately drop out please
forgive me if I heard you wrong at the
beginning but you said something we are
going to be going over to the hill are
you going yourself my people are and
I'll be staying here I'll be in the Oval
Office and various other places in the
White House that matter you're asking
Congress to essentially pass a series of
legislation that's going to amount to
about two trillion dollars 10% of the
GDP what do you say to members in both
parties who say this is too expensive
this is just too much to debate and get
done in 48 hours or so and also have you
spoken directly with Speaker Pelosi you
don't know he's not talking to a race
though I've spoken with I'm not gonna
say who I speak with but I've spoken
with directly or indirectly everybody
many many times we're doing very well I
think the Democrats and the Republicans
are gonna come up with a package that's
going to be huge package really
something very special it's gonna help
people smash this is the first time
there's ever been a case where you want
people not to work it's always you know
you want to create an incentive to work
we're creating not an incentive not to
work but the fact is we're asking people
not to work because of we have to stay
away from each other if we're gonna kill
this horrible hidden enemy we have to
stay away skur there's never been a
thing like this in the history of the
world and the other nations are doing
similar things some effectively some not
effectively they're doing similar things
we are creating a package so it's gonna
keep companies together keep workers
paid so they can live and sustain we'll
see what the timing is the biggest thing
we can do is get rid of the problem the
problem is exactly what we know the
medical problem we want to have this
whole incredible situation that it can
start right away not that all these
companies break up all the workers are
out of jobs you can't put them back
together and it would take years to put
them back together because we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world until we got hit by this problem
and we can be back very very quickly and
it's not intentional act very very
quickly so we're doing a package the
likes of which nobody's ever done before
I'm obviously the one that has to
approve the different things and the
recommendations of the different things
and
like buybacks as an example and stock
buybacks I didn't like it the first time
at this time I'm saying you're not doing
it I don't want money to be used that's
news
I want money to be useful work is he
saying he doesn't want her isn't gonna
be in the kill those not buybacks
well I would I am strongly recommending
a buyback exclusion you cannot buy back
your stock you can't take a billion
dollars of the money and just buy back
your stock and increase the value please
on subject ask the vice president
announced HHS was ordering a hundreds of
millions of them was that ordered Jeff
place today how is that gonna be
distributed in one conductors and nurses
expect to actually receive those max
yeah HHS is completing a half a billion
dollar or of n95 masks and and all of
this is being coordinated through FEMA
and and we're we are responding
specifically to state and requests where
the needs arrived as dr. Fauci said we
want to make sure the people that are
providing health care services to people
who may have contracted coronavirus have
the protection to keep themselves and
their families healthy but I want to
emphasize the the supply of so-called
n95 masks has been so vastly increased
in the country because the president
insisted that we extend liability
protection to industrial masks what all
the experts told us early on was that
industrial mass that are used on
construction sites the president's very
familiar with from his past life
excellent real estate developer
perfectly appropriate to protect health
care workers from respiratory illness
but they didn't have the liability
protection because they weren't created
for hospitals we worked in with leaders
in both parties we added that protection
that runs through 2024 that now the
industrial and 95 mass can be purchased
by hospitals purchased by states
purchased by HHS and distribute through
our systems so we're making those
available the supply has been as I said
vastly increased and it's it was another
step forward in a bipartisan
and we're continuing to use all the kind
of creative means of American industry
to make sure that we're leaning into
this effort and that that we do whatever
it takes to make sure that our
healthcare providers have the protective
equipment so hear from doctors and
nurses about the shortage when exactly
can they expect to receive these masks
though right well let me let let me let
Pete Gaynor speak to anybody mo will be
HHS is now fully integrated into FEMA
and so as the requests come in but
obviously as I'm sure the administrator
will say they're being prioritized to
those areas with the highest need so
within the National Coordination Center
we have a supply chain task force and in
basic sense we try and identify the
universe of what's out there so whether
we hope that at the federal level we
hold it in the private sector and then
match that up with demand and asking
people to be creative we're asking again
this is a shared responsibility we're
asking locals and states to do your
share locally try to take a little bit
burden off of us and then we'll
prioritize those scarce resources
because every single governor across the
country is looking for the exact same
thing so there's a balance but we're
examining the entire supply chain to
make sure that and we make masks start
coming in there they're out there now so
again we want to match we want to get
out of the middle I think so we're
trying to match supplies with demand so
that's what we're doing right now it's
nobody's even expect there the matching
supply demand it is all there's a range
of requests across the country mash
those again supply and demand every day
yeah but I've already come in I have to
tell you the they throwing away of the
mask being in private business they're
throwing away the mask right away
they're thrown away and when you hear 55
million mad I'm saying 55 million how
could it possibly be such a number and
they say oh that's just a small fraction
of what we need and I said why aren't we
sanitizing masks you know you look at
the mess I've looked at all the
different masks Oh some don't lead
themselves just to doing that I think
but many do and I thought that we have
very good liquids for doing this
sanitizing the masks and that's
something they're they're starting to do
more and more the sanitizing the masks
and I don't know if anybody would like
to speak to that
yeah about you you want to talk about
liquids CDC guidance is about how you
can minimize the use of masks by
different things that you could do with
testing and when you have masks how you
might reuse them which ones you can
reuse them you think there's a solution
to this other than buying more massive
care providers need to change how
they're using them as well yeah well
there are a couple of things one for
example we are moving towards getting
testing where you don't have to have PPE
I mean I don't want it I'm not gonna
tell you the day it's gonna be there but
it's gonna be a swab that you could
stick in the nose of the person who is
either infected or not but that person
doesn't need vpe the person who's
administering the test so if you could
do a self administer test stick it in a
vial hand it over you don't need a mask
you don't need PPE that's one of the
things we're trying to do we do and one
other this is another story about a
great American industry oh now the
president and I literally heard directly
from Apple that they're donating two
million industrial masks Tim Apple to
this effort around the country and
working with our administration to
distribute those and it might be a good
opportunity for us to renew our call for
as the president and I delivered this
message to businesses yesterday
manufacturers and small businesses quick
by Apple great time to go to your
storeroom
and if you have in 95 masks if you've
got a hundred of them if you've got
10,000 of them is to load them up drive
them over to your local hospital that
story is literally happening all over
the country and now with more Americans
stepping away from elective surgery
including elective dental care verging
Denys around America to look at their
supplies of n95 mess and make those
available to our hospitals and but the
great news is is the president said the
American people are all doing this now
so allow me to say on behalf of the
president thank you for you all are
doing today but we want to encourage
people in business encourage people
while pence wraps the propaganda did
anybody else notice when the reporter
asked what should people who have laid
off do Trump said keep collecting
paychecks your local hospital would be a
great service to the country some of the
doctors on the front lines of this
crisis are saying doctor these are
doctors who are talking about the
shortage of medical supplies that they
are facing dr. Faisel bucks in Kentucky
says there's absolutely no way to
protect myself a surgeon in Fresno
California says we are at war with no
ammo dr. Mel in Illinois says if this is
a wartime situation then now is the time
to act I know you're talking now about
increasing production at so many of
these facilities to get the masks out
but given that this is one of the
wealthiest most powerful countries in
the world should this even be happening
shouldn't this have been resolved well
I'll tell you the way I look at it so
many administrations preceded me no they
did very little in terms of what you're
talking about this is unprecedented you
could speak to Tony you can speak to
anybody this is unprecedented or just
about unprecedented as time goes by
we're saying it's really at a level that
nobody would have believed nobody would
have thought possible that this could
happen and we are making much of this
stuff now and much of it's being
delivered now we've also gotten
tremendous reviews from a lot of people
they can't believe how fast it's coming
when when I hear they have an order or
55 bin
in masks and that's just one order
that's one order out of many and that
there are many millions of masks beyond
that that and I keep saying how is it
possible to use so much but that's the
way it is and part of that is because
they they'll use a mask for a short
period of time and they throw it the
fact is that we are doing a tremendous
amount we started with very few masks we
had some but nothing for an event like
this and now we're making tens of
millions of masks and other things and I
think it's unprecedented what we've done
and what we're doing and many doctors
that I've read many many doctors they
can't believe the great job that we've
done yes Kelly well if you remember I
was knowing that I was the one that
closed the country down I was going to
close the you know write that or you
don't say it too much certainly on CNN
but just read an article yesterday that
by closing the country down so early so
very early we saved tens of thousands
and much more than that lives so you
know you might want to report that I
just like to address that for a moment
again I'm an ICU physician ran health
systems and I first of all want to thank
everyone who's on the front line in the
emergency room and the ICUs and the
hospitals I speak to my colleagues daily
we need to preserve our PPE to the
degree that we can CDC guidelines has
had that the president has talked about
it but I also want to say we are making
product as the president said but we are
also responding through the FEMA system
to distribute the strategic national
stockpile resources according to
requests that come in stockpile has been
distributed to many states first orders
second orders and on a daily basis
adjudicating that if there are shortages
in your hospital system I can't tell you
of dr. XYZ that needs to be clearly
iterated to the local emergency
management
hospitals talking about we were on the
phone nights ago or three nights ago
with over two thousand hospitals or
hospital systems sharing best practices
from Seattle where they've been very
innovative pioneering some of these
areas when there is a shortage they need
to go through their emergency management
it goes directly up to the FEMA system
which really rocks
it really works very very well and then
there's a distribution of the stockpile
now the stockpile is an infinite that's
why it's being replaced by all the
orders but
masks supplies go out on a daily basis
as they are needed and requested through
the FEMA system an administrator gain or
whether you want to add to that so just
to reiterate what would Whitbread said
we don't take lightly what you just read
you know I mean I get the calls every
night the way you get emails it's a
serious issue we don't want that to
happen but it is happening you're not
making things up like I know that
because I'm experiencing myself but what
you junk doesn't like that for Avenues
some of which aren't even recognized
about how you can get help through the
FEMA process in addition to the large
amounts of additional PPE that's coming
into the system
we hope that very very very soon we're
not going to get those kinds of
real-life difficulties there's a
question about the timeline here and
even FEMA can't quite answer what what
the timeline is days weeks
yeah yeah sooner than weeks it's it's
it's gonna be days I would hope you know
I hope we're gonna try to make it days
to the best possible way we can and
again what we're doing is we're trying
to help the states get things faster and
that's what we're doing we're
implementing and the magnitude of this
it's a tragedy it's an absolute tragedy
but the magnitude is something that no
matter who you were no matter where you
come from nobody ever thought a thing
like this could happen you read about
maybe BC about certain things but you
think in a modern age a thing like that
could never happen well it comes back it
is genius it comes back and it's too bad
but I think the people working on this
have been incredible at the job they've
done it's really been incredible
but there's tremendous amounts of not
only masks of ventilators and
respirators and everything you can think
of it's all being much of it and almost
I could say all of it as big
manufactured right now
Steve place there were questions about
the use of this malaria drug if those
questions now been resolved well I don't
know that resolved I could say that I'm
going to be distributed I know New York
is getting I think 10,000 units and
numerous other people it's really it
could be the malaria drug plus the z-pak
but and we're gonna find out we're gonna
find out I I feel look I feel as the
expression goes what do we have to lose
because horrible side effects ask about
you'll be very I feel very good about it
Tony would feel you know like he'd like
samples done in a certain way and I
understand that too many doctors agree
with that we get much testing you know
we have a lot of very sick people right
now in hospitals all over the place and
speaking with the governor New York
Cuomo I said how's it look he's got a
lot of sick people so we're going to be
delivering and a lot of samples to New
York and other places and we're gonna
find out very shortly whether or not
it's gonna work I feel very confident I
mean I've seen things that surprised me
frankly there are as Tony said there are
other
things were looking at on vaccine of
course is incredible but this is more
media right now this to me would be the
greatest thing that could happen this
would be a gift from heaven this would
be a gift from God oh my god so we're
gonna pray to God that it does work it
would be a fantastic when you decide to
close down your hotels and your
businesses no I would say but you know
I'm very under levered and everything so
that's good but is it hurting my yeah
it's hurting me and it's hurting Hilton
and it's hurting all of the great hotel
chains all over the world it's hurting
everybody I mean there are very few
business that are doing one now they're
awesome that are it's actually pretty
quick based an example the Walmarts of
the world because everybody's lined up
to get things and stock up their house
and this and that but sure it's my
business but no I didn't speak anybody I
speak to my sons but I talk about the
Carnival is but not as not as violence
to my business they basically follow the
rules when they say close them down in
New York we close them down or wherever
they may be have I actually have them
all over the world and when they say and
when they say close them down we close
them down what Kelly will have nothing
planned at mar-a-lago but right now I
think mar-a-lago I guess I haven't even
asked but I imagine that closed down
just like a lot of other businesses in
Florida she has no idea do you expect
your family companies to seek government
assistance I don't know I mean I just
don't know what the Gaming assistance
would be for what I have I have hotels
how do you not know yours letting you
know I had hotels when I got elected
they knew I was a successful person when
I got a little boy one of those things I
guess I get paid four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year I give it up I
put it back into the nation I usually I
have to by the way you have to designate
where you want it so I often
just give it to opioid you know research
and things but but as far as the the
hotels and everything I mean I have to
do what everyone else is doing I I would
probably decide to close things up I
think it's a good thing nation you don't
want people getting together and hotels
and clubs and everything you get
together we want to beat this deal so I
have many of them hotels clubs things
like that what people get together I
would think would be a good practice to
close I do
I didn't ask everybody here but I
wouldn't be surprised if they had
temperature tests I think they are
pretty much of the easiest thing is that
they are there are big leader I don't
know are you learning a lot from the
temperature test Tony could you maybe
discuss that versus oh boy they have a
place they're not infallible I mean
there's so many ways to get around that
I mean I mean right now every time I
certainly here we get every time I go
into a different room I got my
temperature taken but we see that on the
outside that some people like this very
low there is a role for it under certain
circumstances what I don't see is a
massive distribution of thermometers
that are gonna actually have a major
impact on what I showed what we need to
do right and I say I've seen things
when Tony mentions thermometers they aim
something at your forehead they say this
far away boom and they tell you what
your temperatures I said I've never seen
that before a lot learned a lot it's
incredible go ahead to back to that
corner back
story suggesting that dr. cauchy's
indicated that your action in the
chinese travel ban helped America
immensely what do you say to the
Washington Post this must be a way out
I love whoever you're with it's okay I
think that's such a nice that's such a
nice question it's at the white point no
I think the Washington Post covers us
very inaccurately covers me very
inaccurately I saw the story I think
it's a disgrace but it's the Washington
Post and I guess we have to live with it
it's a very it's a very inaccurate quiet
quiet it's a very inaccurate story from
many people I get a lot of credit for
having closed our country very early to
a very heavily infected country China
unfortunately China I wished I wish
China would have told us more about what
was going on in China long prior to us
reading about it even though the news
isn't exactly disseminated as you know
China kicked the Washington Post out of
China and they kicked the New York Times
out of chair I guess the Wall Street
Journal that's okay I mean that's what
they do and I think it's a terrible
thing they did but I also think it's
terrible when people write in accurately
about you and they write in accurately
about me every single day every single
hour and by the way your group really I
really think and I just say first though
he doesn't know where and I think you
write very fairly and do very fair
reports about the great job the way all
of us are doing that this group behind
me is doing it's so insulting when they
write phony stories that they know are
fake news because they're not insulting
me they're insulting everybody these
incredible people that have worked so
hard so long that are thinking about
nothing other than this invisible enemy
they have done such an incredible job
and these email thermometer clear we're
gonna win my weapons and there'll be a
lot of celebration where we win and
we're gonna win with as few lives lost
as possible that's the game win with as
few lives lost as possible it's a tough
enemy it's a tough killer far bigger far
more vicious than ever before but I
appreciate you saying it because the
fact that we closed so early to China
and
most people Hey look I was called
xenophobic by sleepy Joe Biden I was
called a racist by Democrats there is a
racist because I decided that I didn't
want to have people that could hurt our
country come in and I was pretty much in
a very small group of people I will tell
you it was a tiny little group most
people even that worked in the White
House disagreed with me very strongly
saving of those many weeks was a
tremendous worth scrutinize a tremendous
thing and when they keep talking about
acting early that was the ultimate act
that was the biggest act it was an act
because we didn't and then I'll also
closed Europe early very early
he closed Europe and I took a lot of
heat for that too but that was a good
thing now they're doing similar things
that would so I didn't act late I acted
early I acted far before anybody thought
I should be
I took tremendous criticism from the
various papers from many of the papers
services I very much appreciate the
question it might have been it might
have been more of a statement than a
question but whatever it may have been I
appreciated for him right she loved the
state's kind of done these different
measures we've seen California order one
in New York you know just be similar do
you want all the states to do one
uniform no no they they can do what they
want to do if California can get a mask
sooner than we can get it for them
through all of the things we're able to
do but we're gonna end up with a big
oversupply at some point you know at
some point this is going away and we're
gonna end up with a big oversupply and
you know what in this case that's gonna
be okay
but if California if Gavin can go out
and order gowns faster or masks good
masks faster or other things faster
that's good we do have a lot of I mean
the coordination with the ships that
we're sending in as you know the the
medical ships that we're sending in and
even cruise liners we're going to be
sending in probably cruise liners into
some areas in particular California and
in particular New York but if somebody
can do something faster if they can
order that mask faster than us I want
them to be a better
so people can't leave their homes that
you know certain businesses that record
it very much with them you say well I
just don't have to be at this moment
because we have places in the country
where you know states where they have
two people with three people and those
people are in quarantine and you can't
put on them what you're putting in New
York well you do have a tremendous
problem I mean we have large portions of
the country
middle America where you know they have
a few people so it may be a time I hope
that never happens where we need to take
very drastic action but right now that's
not in the same ballpark
yeah go ahead please we're day six and
you're 15 days of recommendations a lot
of people are following them some people
are not if you think the American people
are doing enough right now too slow I
think there are and some people are not
but I think they are and some people or
not that that's another profound
affected me we'll know a little bit more
on day 14 and 15 we'll see what we're
gonna see we have to see what the result
is we want to flatten that out and we're
going to see what the result is and and
I just want to say I'm going to
negotiate a very large transaction and
I've been negotiating it for two days so
I'm gonna take one or two more questions
and then I'm gonna leave it to vice
president pence with the various the
various elements of the package elements
of package number of groups are calling
for the postponement or cancellation of
the Olympics have you given a third no I
haven't I look we understand the
difficulty of that and he's a very good
friend of mine you you took a look you
take a look at Shinzo Abby he's a he's a
great gentleman he loves his country we
have an incredible relationship we just
finished a trade deal with him 40
billion dollar trade deal with Japan and
Prime Minister Robby has a big decision
to make you know they they have built
one of the most beautiful venues I've
ever seen they're all ready to go it's
not late it's not over budget it's not
it was just done flawlessly and it's
beautiful and they're sitting back and
saying you know I I have I told him I
said that's your decision and it is his
decision and I know he's going to make
it soon I don't know what it's going to
be and I didn't think I should be
influencing it at all I mean the job
that Japan is
that venue is incredible so I mean there
are options obviously including delay
and maybe delay for next year but that's
totally up to them we'll see what they
do when did you first learn that this
was gonna be a problem well you know
when I learned I started doing the
closing so you know probably around that
time well I learned much I think I'm
gonna ask a little bit about China
responsibilities I do think that again I
have great respect for China lie
I like China I I think the people of
China are incredible a tremendous
relationship with President Xi I wish
they could have told us earlier about
what was going on and said we didn't
know about it until it started coming up
in January but I wish they could have
told us earlier about because we could
have come up with a solution
Tony foul Qi and all of the people the
talent that we have would have loved to
have had three or four months of
additional time if you knew that this
was going to be happening they didn't
have that he guess yes sir mister they
read about it in the newspapers like
everybody else it's guys lying the China
was very secretive okay she knows he's
alive and that's unfortunate
with that I have great respect for that
country I have great respect wrong for
the leader of that country and like it
he's a friend of mine but I wish they
were able to I wish they would have told
us earlier Steve not an answer that they
was when does it having a big problem
and they knew it and I wish they could
have given us an advanced warning
because we could have done question was
when a lot of us as an example some of
the things that we're talking about will
we order them as quickly as we can if we
had a two or three month difference in
time it would have been much better yeah
what a liar on that because as you're
st. China was extremely secretive about
this
several of your advisors have been
warning have been critical of China
secretary Pompey was talking about it
yesterday and he had been saying so for
quite some time so why then on January
24th did you tweet that China has been
working very hard to contain the
coronavirus that the United States
greatly appreciates their efforts and
transparency because it's because it's
showing that china has worked very hard
China's lost thousands and thousands of
people
so China was first hiding transparent on
January 24 and Trump did nothing till
February in March what China just so you
understand China's not a beneficiary or
China has lost thousands and thousands
of people China has gone through hell
over this they've gone through hell and
I've had conversations with President Xi
I just wish they could have told us
earlier they knew they had a problem
earlier I wish they could have said that
on number of available tests on number
of leaders in the federal stockpile well
I'm gonna leave that up to dr. Fauci and
everybody else and I think the answer is
we want to share them I would imagine we
want to share the numbers as nobody
wants to decide and they're due for
delivery delivery contagious has 18
months the last number of educators we
have is 12 to 13 thousand and give us an
updated number you know a ventilator is
a machine it's a very complex machine
and 200 of them see nobody's ever heard
of a thing but it was food you know when
we had in the stockpile we had thousands
in a stockpile of thousands ready to go
that's a lot all of a sudden you need
hundreds of thousands and you're not
talking about you know the mask is
whether it's plastic or whether it's
material that's one thing but you're
talking about
a very sophisticated computerized
machined and delicate and you need
hundreds of thousands of them nobody's
ever heard of a thing like that with
that being said General Motors Ford so
many companies I had three calls
yesterday directly without having to
institute like you will do this these
companies are making
right now but to think of these numbers
it's it's pretty the worst one out it's
pretty much air with us right now well
you bet well we spoke a lot about mass
this morning but the president's also
given the task force a priority of
assessing the availability and expanding
the number of ventilators and on Monday
we will detail some very encouraging
news for Americans you speak about the
number of 13,000 it is a little more
than that that we have in the national
stockpile but it's important to remember
that that doesn't include the more than
a hundred thousand ventilators that are
in health care facilities and hospitals
around America today
it doesn't include what will be produced
as the president said we're seeing
companies step forward
well these manufacturers tell us that a
ventilator actually isn't a very
complicated piece of equipment and men
just said it is literally surging
forward to create more ventilators but
one of the more exciting developments in
the last week which will detail more on
Monday is that in in the president's
engagement with our health care
community we learned that that
ventilators that are currently used by
anesthesiologists that are used in
outpatient clinics and in other
procedures can be converted to be used
as ventilators for people struggling
with the effects of the corona virus
we've confirmed that a particular screen
in that device can be changed readily
we're working with the FDA to approve
that but again this is a it's a great
testament of the American people and our
health care professionals that are
amazing time to be alive and and
bringing ideas forward that that
literally as well document Monday will
increase the supply of ventilators
ventrally notice how Trump just talked
about how complex ventilators are and
pens just said they're really not
complicated and we can retrofit existing
machines or serving
in healthcare around America have the
support they need that our patients that
are struggling with recovering from
coronavirus I have the equipment they
need and we'll have we'll have a lot of
detail on Monday as we continue to
assess somebody answer your question and
then try to try to persuade you to stop
asking about a specific number okay so
from March 2nd to March 14th we have put
over 10 million laboratory tests into
the US commercial market and we expect
that by March 28th to be well over 27
million into the market so that answers
your question and let me tell you why
it's not the right question and no one's
I think every lab can run every test not
every test is completely self-contained
so the more important question is not
how many tests are in the market we got
them in the market but is to make sure
that every segment of the market
has the kind of test that they can use
the things you've promised are happen
yes they are happen
they are but stopped as promised 1 or 4
million there's 10 million tests in the
market now are the masks that are in the
strategic reserve being deployed mr.
vice president
yes the masks in the strategic national
stockpile 13,000 anymore it would be a
lower number would that be fair to say a
ventilator your ventilators I'm sorry
the
thank you we're trying to understand if
the things we have been told sitting
through these briefings for many days
are happening they're not getting into
the hands of the healthcare providers
you're an intelligent woman Kelly you
understand exactly what you say and what
are you saying is rather incredible
because we've been completely and
utterly no one believed and when you
hear the number of tests that we'll be
providing and are now it's incredible
and I've heard a lot of governor's say
the same thing we took over an obsolete
broken testing system that wouldn't have
worked for even a small problem let
alone one of the biggest pandemics in
history and what these gentlemen have
done is incredible I am going now to
negotiate a great deal for our workers
and our citizens I'll be back tomorrow
we're probably doing this tomorrow well
if I might I'd like to ask vice
president pence to take over and thank
you all very much all right guys that's
as far as I'm going with it today it's
getting very toxic and we're just gonna
hear Pence's lies so if you must
continue it'll have to continue
elsewhere I will cover the next one
tomorrow hopefully some doctors will
tell us things